[Musique]
philippe deviez bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
direct est ce que vous vous est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
je suis né le 25 mars 1949 à wohlen un
petit village de la vendée où j'ai
grandi
ensuite
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de dessiner une voie
d'avenir
je voulais pas travailler dans le public
parce que je savais que j'étais
indisciplinés je voulais pas travailler
dans le privé parce que je voulais pas
vendre de cacahuètes
et je voulais en fait j'avais une
passion
c'était la vendée et je voulais faire un
hymne
et mon père me disait t'as rien pour
faire un hymne tellement incompétents
artistiquement qu'il n'a pas
d'expérience tu es trop jeune dans un
pays de gérontocratie avant de laisser
les lieux qui commande vous taillez
faire l'ena si tu fais lainage fait un
pacte avec toi je te laisserais faire
tourner mais
je suis parti à paris faire l'ena
sciences po l'ena et le soir de mon
admission à l'ena j'ai appelé mon père
et je lui ai dit voilà
est-ce que tu peux me prêter mille
francs à l'époque pour acheter une 4l
d'occasions pour tourner en vendée
cherchez un lieu trouver un lieu pour
faire mon hymne et j'ai féminine qui
s'appelle le puy du fou
est en fait tout d'un coup je me suis
dit ah oui mais je me suis mis un fil à
la patte le puy du fou tu vas vivre sa
vie et en même temps je sort de l'ena je
suis sous préfet comment je vais amener
de vie donc j'ai mené pendant sa saison
deux vies parallèles la vie publique
et le puy du fou en fait la vie publique
a été pour moi
une variable d'ajustement
je suis père de famille
j'habite aux herbiers près du puy du fou
j'ai été
donc dans la vie alors en fait j'aime
angie
d'octroi vie en même temps première vit
une vie d'entrepreneur créateur
bénévoles je suis toujours bénévole au
puy-du-fou
n'ont aucun droit d'auteur au plus chaud
que
je donnais une date le 11 mars 1978 j'ai
réuni les 200 premiers curieux qui
allaient devenir les premiers puyfolais
comme on dit maintenant vers les membres
actifs de l'association que les fous je
suis monté sur une barrique et je leur
ai dit voilà
vous me prenez pour un fou mais un jour
le monde entier viendra ici et je fais
devant vous 4 serment pas de droit
d'auteur pour le créateur parce que
c'est un acte d'amour et pas un acte de
business
pas de subvention parce que je pas
compte des pentes du marketing électoral
pas de brevet extérieur par des brevets
américains je rêve - ou peut-être mais
tout seul cyrano et et pas de formations
extérieures enfin tout nous mêmes et en
fait
45 ans après j'ai quatre serment on ont
été respectés sont toujours respectés et
c'est ce qu'a fait notre force et notre
indépendance indépendance technologique
on a nos propres inventeur nos propres
inventions indépendance pédagogique on a
nos écoles indépendance artistique fait
tout nous-mêmes et indépendance
financière économique
puisqu'on est totalement indépendant
voilà alors c'est ça c'est la vie du
créateur de l'entrepreneur
g après été élu président du conseil
général de la vendée puis députés
choisis par jacques chirac pour être
mises la culture en 86
j'ai abandonné la politique j'ai quitté
la vie politique active en il ya dix ans
et une troisième vie en fait qui prend
de plus en plus de place dans ma fille
c'est la vie
de l'auteur de l'écrivain puisque là je
viens de sortir à à livre qui s'appelle
le jour d'après chez albin michel vous
allez côte est ont parlé je vais vous
poser une question qui me vient à
l'esprit comme ça qu'est ce que ça fait
comme sensation d'être absous par
l'histoire c'est à dire vous êtes parti
contre tous
personne croyant vous
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'avoir été
absous par d'histoire vous avez réussi
le puy du fou marche fonctionne
en termes de sensations ça fait quoi ces
jeunes aura pas bien compte en fait
sauf que le regard des journalistes par
exemple pas changé comme mon départ j'ai
été agressé tout le temps
des exemples en fait il ya un champ il
s'appelle pascal praud qui m'a dit
un jour il ya pas longtemps tu as été
massacrés par les guignols il nous nous
c'est ça oui en fait puis le canard
enchaîné l'agité du bocage et sida et en
fait quand vous dites absous par
l'histoire s'est absout deux fois
j'étais vendéen et je voulais faire
reconnaître
ce qui s'était passé en vendée
et en fait j'ai réussi à faire venir
soljenitsyne en 1993
et l'a dit cette phrase
à la fin de son grand discours en
inaugurant un mémorial un jour les
français seront fiers du sacrifice de la
vendée
et maintenant c'est le cas
on ne peut plus le nier ce qui s'est
passé en vendée d'autant plus que la
vendait une miniature de la france et
que c'est une petite france aimante
qui a qui a dominé sa souffrance et
qu'il a sublimé et alors vous dites
absous par l'histoire je vis ça en ce
moment avec le commissaire qu'en fait et
encore dix ans quand j'allais sur un
plateau
je disais pas un peu un pk pas de
frontières ça se termine mal
un monde sans frontières ce titanic
quand j'ai créé le vendée globe avec
philippe jeantot on a fait des
compartiments étanches les nations sont
les compartiments étanches de la
mondialisation
d'élèves les chaînes de valeur globale
vous verrez ça pétera jour
la religion des flux pas de stocks que
des flux
la délocalisation systématique
j'entendais giscard madelin tous les
autres qu'ils aient plus d'industrie
laissons les chinois laissons les les
japonais
les indiens de son émoi jeudi mais vous
savez les indiens sont peu plus grand
que nous un jour il y aura des
informaticiens indiens sait pas plus
mais elle disait alors nous on leur
laisse le primaire et le secondaire
donc c'est l'om c'est l'organisation
commerciale du monde enfin déjà plus ça
comme ça et puis on se dit toute façon
les chinois va ils font
ils feront ils reprendront le secteur
primaire le secteur secondaire mais nous
on aura le tertiaire le quaternaire dix
écoles quaternaire bon de
l'administratif s'éteint et puis
finalement on se retrouve en boxer sur
le récent
sur le remblai au bord de la plage en
fait trempette y'a plus rien et donc en
fait tout ce qu'on avait dit je sais que
c'est moi qui a inventé le mot
souverainisme pour la première fois en
2004 devant l'institut de france j'étais
invité à parler de l'europe et à
l'époque on use la c1 tout québécois
souverainiste mais aujourd'hui
tout le monde est un peu souverainiste
donc en fait les frontières la question
des chaînes valeur globale la question
de l'industrie les délocalisations
la question de plus généralement de
l'indépendance de la souveraineté
elle est au coeur du débat politique
le mot souveraineté était interdite a
encore dix ans qui par les élites c'est
quoi les élites globalisé c'est qu'une
élite club et l'isi a
lésé league le réaliser c'est les gens
qui
exercent le magistère médiatico
politique français c'est à dire que
pendant des années pendant des décennies
pour être au pouvoir
il fallait être pour maastricht donc
fallait être pour une europe
il fallait pour la gouvernance globale
d'une europe cheval de troie de la
mondialisation
je vous raconte une anecdote pour vous
répondre
un jour j'étais avec parce qu elle se
gare
et il ya de l'or qui nous regardent qui
nous pointe comme ça du doigt et qui me
dit vous
vous devriez quitter la politique
alors pourquoi parce que il reprend une
phrase d'alain minc
élite globalisé si l'on ai dit vous êtes
sorti du cercle de la raison
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sortir du
cercle de la raison
sortir du cercle de la raison c'est dire
ce que disait pascal boutan saguenay qui
s'est fait n'est pas
ce qu'une nation ne le fait pas pour
elle-même
personne ne le fera jamais à sa place
et là en fait quand on entend une aile
macro qui dit il ya un an le virus n'a
pas de passeport
que on se retrouve avec une frontière
domestique confirmé chez soi
la frontière ça existe quand tu veux pas
installer une frontière une barrière
douanière tu fais les gestes barrières
et ça se termine avec le masque assigné
à résidence
donc
[Musique]
en fait tout ce qu'on disait
s'est avéré vrai des aînés de globaliser
pour vous répondre de manière complète
ce sont des gens qui sont aux commandes
et ils sont tous commandes parce que
veut bien
pardon parce que me veux bien oui on le
veut bien mais parce que
et son dépositaire d'une idéologie qui
en fait
provoque la faillite des peuples
l'idéologie
de dinde un monde où les ponts viendrait
remplacer les murs au nom de la
fraternité cosmique en it et cosmique à
la fraternité cosmique bas
c'est l'idée
qu' il faut plus sauver son petit coin
de pays sa bourgogne savants des il faut
plus sauvé
safran ce qui
est appelé à devenir un espace
expérimental
où on fait venir des populations de
partout en reconstruisant une société
j'aurais été le cas en france on a eu
beaucoup de mouvements migratoires non
non non non justement
je vous réponds tout de suite là dessus
non en fait
le mois j'ai cru ça quand j'étais à
sciences po à l'énorme disait sa bouche
des crues la france a toujours été un
pays d'immigration séjour jusqu'à
1900 jusqu'à 1914
la france était un pays d'émigration
il ya eu très peu de brassage de
population en fait les burgondes ses
tâches comme ça par coeur léger bas je
fais partie des gens pour étudier la
question parce que quand j'entendais mon
ami bernard stasi dire là l'immigration
est une chance pour la france il nous
expliquer mais ç'a toujours été comme ça
donc pas de panique
à partir de la première guerre mondiale
aient eu à
un déficit démographique et l'orne a
fait venir des gens mais on a fait venir
en fait des populations qui venait de la
même culture que nous donc ça pas poser
de problème encore que
son parti alors voilà pierre mais a
quitté mon prof à sciences po grand
professeur d'histoire disait que sur 3
millions d'italiens
qui sont venus en france pour chercher
du travail et qui ont été plutôt bien
accueilli
sur 3 millions il ya là
deux millions qui sont repartis parce
qu'il ne se faisait pas aux moeurs de la
france mais la grande innovation
tu essaies c'est giscard
enfin non ça commençait compile ou qu'un
cd au patronat françois ceyrac qui était
à l'époque président du cnpf m'a dit un
jour c'est de la folie les patrons se
rendent pas compte de ce qu'ils sont
des patrons qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
en fait à l'époque il allait voir pour
piles ou pour dire
voilà notre note la manoeuvre trop cher
vous faire venir des maghrébins
on les paye quelques sous et puis c'est
bon alors au début tout va bien
trop quand même y avait des bidonvilles
c'était c'était c'était très dur
oui c'est à dire au début tout va bien
pour les patrons
sauf que ont des dons des racines un peu
le pays ont des racines un peu le
travail et puis évidemment jusqu'à
arrive et effet en fait le regroupement
familial
1974 175 jacques chirac et là on fait
venir là on passe d'une migration de
travail immigration de peuplement
et quand vous regardez la suite c'est
terrible la responsabilité d'homme
politique c'est terrible ce que je
raconte dans mon lieu
en amitié ans j'ai bien connu puisque
j'ai été moi au gouvernement et il se
trouve que mitterrand aimait bien parce
qu'il disait vous me rappelez moi jeune
dire que quand ils étaient jeunes
étaient de droite et provinciales pas
loin de chez moi en charente françois
hollande dont un peu comme françois
hollande sauf que
j'avais tourné c'est ça voilà l'homme et
françois on n'avait pas les racines de
météo mitterrand fait était un homme de
droite il était très enracinée et en
fait muter en un jour julie vous rendez
compte que vous avez dit les étrangers
sont chez eux chez nous ils ont gauche
sont très heureux si nous aussi
alors il ya beaucoup de gens de gauche
qui sont très enracinée
ledent
d'ailleurs c'est le drame de la gauche
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle est conduite
par des gens qui ont répudié leurs
propres racines
et qui s'appuie sur
des communautés extérieures
qui sont elles mêmes déracinés et
le critère d'une vie politique
démocratique
d'alternance
c'est une harmonie supérieur
qui vient du fait qu'on est d'accord sur
la point l'homme pour survivre a besoin
du mus et de lumière
et donc en fait quand je pense à
hollande nous parler de hollande dont
les comptes ce qui la fait hollande
terra nova
terra nova c'est un film fang qui a dit
à hollande bon écoute et voilà en 1983
on a joué le libre échange à fond et on
a considéré que l'industrie c'est fini
ce que pour des fab us à l'époque on
allait quitter la classe ouvrière
les délocalisations donc une fois
prolétariat substitution on l'a trouvé
lou mène trop l'état substitution donc
les immigrés est ce à ce racisme comme
disait baudrillard elle souhaite raciste
a un point commun avec sos baleine c'est
que cette sauver les racistes comme il
faut sauver les baleines
c'est sauver ceux qui sont victimes du
racisme voilà en fait c'était ça mais
c'était en même temps l'idée qu'il
fallait fabriquer du racisme pour
pouvoir créer un conflit est fabriqué
une extrême droite c'était ça l'idée de
mitterrand pour gagner les élections
pour gagner les élections et terra nova
c'était l'idée de
dire à hollande il faut vous appuyez sur
les minorités pour gagner et
le souhaitent les élites globalisé pense
que
le libre échangisme mondial
permet seule de s'enrichir
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il enrichit
surtout les géants du numérique et pense
que les nations sont dépassés qu'elles
sont périmés et qu'il s'agit maintenant
de sauver la planète mais moi je le dis
pour sauver la planète faut d'abord
sauver les nations c'est à dire toutes
les communautés d'appartenance qui
permettent
l'expression de l'universalisme de
gaulle disait la nation et le chemin de
l'universel
et on voit bien par exemple l'europe
actuelle où les nations se délite
dans l'europe at elle se l'europe
actuelle se délite aussi d'élite ou se
disloque des deux va se disloque ceux
des stocks mais aussi
connaît un phénomène d'implosion
pourquoi ah ben c'est simple
parce qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'on aurait
dû faire
au moment de maastricht il ya eu une
grande europe celle d'aden aux arts du
général de gaulle
lors des six
ce pardon europe des six exactement mais
on aurait pu être plus nombreux la
coalition de garder les deux principes
que qu'on avait et qui ont qui ont fait
que de gaulle a accepté deux ans 58 un
an après le précédent de continuer l
aventure le premier principe vous êtes
trop jeune pour l'avoir connu c'était la
préférence communautaire c'est à dire
qu'en fait on faisait un marché commun
un marché commun ça veut dire que si on
fabrique du miel on va d'abord consommer
notre miel le miel européen avant
d'aller chercher lui miel en afrique du
sud du protectionnisme c'était un
protectionnisme à l'échelle de l'europe
ça fonctionnait bien marché commun et
d'ailleurs l'agriculture etc
pardon du charbon charbon c'est au
départ mais après l'industrie
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait à airbus si
on avait l'idée part d'une industrie
européenne et
c'était l'idée pour la france du levier
d'archimède
le levier d'archimède c'est l'europe
nous grandit nous la france parce que ce
sera une grande france et le l'autre
principe
essentiel c'était la coopération des
états s'est il y avait le conseil et la
commission était un exécutant
au nom de maastricht et 2 novation
nageurs on a fait sauter la préférence
communautaire on est passé au libre
échange mondial et à ce moment là
l'europe est devenu une passoire
dans tous les sens du terme passoire
pour les hommes par si on veut pas
s'asseoir pour les marchandises on a
adopté pour les taxes bien sûr c'est
dire qu'en fait on est à caravansérail
ouvert au monde entier et deuxièmement
on a remplacé la coopération par
l'intégration c'est à dire que c'est la
commission qui est devenu le
gouvernement l'exécutif et non plus
l'exécutant et là ça change tout on le
voit avec le vaccin parce que en fait
quand vous avez un gouvernement il sera
l angleterre
il se démerde
pardon mais sert qu'aux gouvernements
anglaise vivons nous avec oxford cette
arme
rendez compte que moi je suis nantais
enfin tout près 90 et je connais bien là
le veinard la la c'est notre dame des
landes oui absolument et valbuena
c'était une entreprise nantaise
française prometteuse son parti auction
est donc souhaité comme quand vous êtes
une nation êtes agile regardez israël
regarder angleterre et quand et où
démerder ça veut dire que vous dites bon
il faut que
jeudi à risque bon je suis tout seul
parce qu'on est tout seul effectivement
la mondialisation heureuse de sourires
des ravis les santons de provence
si j'ai pas de masse comme les chinois
abandonneront cerner mais ça marche pas
comme ça la vie ça marche pas comme ça
et alors maquereau en fait qu a voulu
faire un coup il est allé voir merkel
jusque là l'histoire par coeur attendez
oui
on est d'accord sur le constat
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant parce
que c'est pas la classe politique qui va
nous aider ce problème pour eux est
inextricable la question je vous pose
c'est ont-ils réellement compris les
dégâts
cette subornation de vote depuis des
années votez pour moi je président du
pouvoir d'achat votez pour moi je vous
donne des logements votez pour moi je
vous arroserait ça nous emmène là les
poches sont vides
la france est en faillite
où on est on est la mer se retirer comme
vous l'avez dit on est en short
on est à l'eau peut-être je ne l'espère
pas d'insurrection de révolte
de soulèvement qu'est ce qu'on fait
alors attendez attendez vous à nos
portes il ya des gens qui meurent là
encore ce matin je suis tombé sur une
vidéo de la police espagnole qui
remettait des gens à la mer en leur
tapant dessus on paye des turcs pour
éviter que nos populations ce passeur
envahir et que et que ça ce stock chez
chez eux que le problème soit soient
gérés par d'autres
mais ça reste des hommes vous êtes
chrétien oui vous vous croyez en dieu
vous avez un ami imaginaire
g
je crois
dans le christ et c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile à
comprendre mais on comprend que tu on a
perdu quelqu'un de proche c'est ce qu'on
appelle la communion des saints dire
qu'en fait ea dans le sky
des gens qui sont une partie de soi même
mon père ma mère ma soeur bibiane
et je leur parle en fait et je leur
demande et en fait ça veut dire je crois
à quelque chose qui dépasse la mort et
qui est la vie et que la vie continue
parce que je peux pas je peux pas
imaginer que l'on parlait ma mère soit
mort et ils vivent autrement et un jour
il ya un prêtre qui m'a dis à ton père
est parti de là où il est et continuera
à thé des échanges tout ça merveilleux
c'est un espèce de maternité de
paternité
éternel quand on a en santé on est on a
quelque chose d'éternel est en fait
être chrétien
c'est croire
qu' il ya au dessus de la santé qui
était un bien des valeurs supérieures
dont la charité
dont le pardon et le gris c'est ce qu'il
fait là monavie la supériorité du
christianisme
qui a créé cette civilisation qui sont
en train de mourir c'est le pardon et le
pardon c'est la chose la plus impossible
le plus difficile à pratiquer et que
j'avais qualifié un jour devant sur le
gène chine à propos de la révolution
française de l'aduges de la vendée le
pardon mme montchamp c'est le pardon
cette alchimie du sentiment qui
convertit le mal an nouvelle chance
et en fait c'est al pardon la société ce
crochet des harmonies on les retrouve
c'est à pales pardon c'est oeil pour
dent il pourrait y dent pour dent et ça
devient infernal et dans ce que vous
dites à propos de deux des gens qui
tombent à la mer
pas tout seul oui on leur taper dessus
oui à l'europe oui donc en fait
en fait
qu'est-ce que c'est un chrétien quand
ils voient ça va s'avérer plus il se dit
la chose suivante
heureux celui qui a une appartenance à
l'enracinement
un pays
les gens qui laisse partir ses
misérables
en leur faisant croire que ils vont être
heureux chez nous alors que chez nous il
ya plus de travail il ya le désordre et
l'insécurité ils rendent pas service à
ces gens
et je trouve odieux que par exemple
et les médecins qui ont fait venir chez
nous maintenant il le dit pas s'avérant
mais moi je le sais on les fait venir
l'afrique parce qu'ils sont moins chers
informés
et donc en fait l'occident
fait venir viendra sur le dépeuplement
des élites africaines absolument mais là
ce que ce tout s'est tu veux dire c'est
que c'est que en fait ce n'est pas un
destin met en relation que pop pour les
pour les pauvres de quitter leur pays le
quitter leur héritage de quitter leur
parenté et là aussi c'est le principe
des des communauté des nations
le seul hic quand moi quand j'étais
petit à boulogne dans mon village
pardon mais
vous allez voir ce que je vais vous dire
quand quelqu'un glissé au fossé
il y avait une main tendue tout de suite
c'était le voisin c'était le parent
c'était le frère c'était la soeur et
puis après si tuteurs des instituteurs
et
longtemps après ce telle mère et
longtemps après stelletta maintenant on
a fait on a fabriqué un hybride le
solidaire solitaire
on n'a jamais été si solidaire jamais si
solitaire le solidaire solitaire on lui
balance une prestation au fossé évident
matnik ferme ta gueule tu bouffes mais
dans le meilleur des cas mais cette
relation abstraite entre
celui qui est dans le besoin dans tous
les sens du terme et la puissance
publique c'est une société qui se
dessèchent
question d'homme à homme quand vous
voyez un gamin qui est brûlé à l'essence
parce qu'il a passé 18 heures dans un
zodiac
qui la fuient les marchés aux esclaves
en libye ou qui la traversaient la
montagne ou qu'il a nagé pour récupérer
nos côtes quand vous le voyez terminer
dans un centre de rétention
administratif dans le meilleur des cas
ou quand vous le voyez débarquer en
turquie ou en grèce où il ya un gogo
pour 5000 personnes
vous en tant qu'homme
ça vous fait quoi
alors il y à des gamines qui se font
violer parler aux gens
traumatisés one quand vient le temps
comme
moi je suis un homme politique je veux
pas de nom justement je te tuer
le premier réflexe
évidemment c'est la compassion
est un homme qui n'a pas la compassion
n'est plus tout à fait humain
donc une fois qu'on a ce cru
c'est humain désespérée
des racines et à moitié brûlé
qui souffrent une fois qu'on a ce cour
rue parce que c'est l'honneur de la
civilisation c'est le principe du bon
samaritain
il faut se tourner vers l'homme
politique pour lui dire comment tu as pu
laisser faire ça
c'est là que je le dis je suis un homme
politique c'est à dire que en permanence
jeu alors je suis plus mais je raisonne
en dix ans
la phrase de bossuet
il y a des gens qui chérissent
nom qui est qui et comment ce qui se
plaignent
les effets des maux dont ils chérissent
les causes en d'autres termes
organisons le monde pour que on soit pas
dans cette situation en tout cas le
moins possible alors autant commencer
trop tard alors c'est pas trop tard pas
du tout pas du tout inertie sociétale à
l'échelle mondiale non là le moi je
pense que
on est justement en une période où tout
est possible parce qu'on redécouvre des
notions essentielles à la faveur du co
vite par exemple on re découvre que la
souveraineté c'est pas trop tard on va
en parler sous les enfin j'espère
parce que pour moi c'est un truc les
trois heures formidable
le
moi je crois
à l'enracinement
christopher lasch un grand sociologue
américain dès
le déracinement des racines tout sauf le
besoin la racine mans et l'enracinement
ça veut dire qu'en fait on a un double
regard on a un regard sur son prochain
soit pour le sauver soi pour qu'il nous
sauve
et donc on a un début de société
robinson vendredi et à regard sur le
monde
parce que le particulier donne le goût
de l'universel palente moi quand je suis
au b1 avec j'aime beaucoup quand je suis
au liban j'ai la nationalité libanaise
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai rendu service
au général aoun quand je suis en espagne
à tolède on n'a plus du tout maintenant
je me sens très vite chez moi je l'aimé
c'est curieux ça c'est pourtant très
différent parce que quand vous êtes
enraciné
vous vous avez en vous une espèce de
lois de l'hospitalité qui se déplace et
qui devient universelle
c'est plus on est particulier peut en
est universel c'est comme les écossais à
bayonne mais ne fait rien
oui mais dire
moi ce que ce qui me fait peur ce serait
un monde unique où tout est unique où il
ya plus de tradition il ya plus de
coutume où il ya plus de particularités
où tout le monde le monde degré tatin
berg
d'ailleurs d'écologie si vous voulez
bien oui ça doit être de greta
thannberger ben c'est l'idée que quand
elle dit qu'il faut sauver la planète
moi je dis
bien sûr je suis pas content mais faut
d'abord sauver l'arbre qui à côté de soi
là
le petit arbre
c'est à dire que on ne va à l'universel
on ne devient universel que c'est on
s'enracine dans le dans le dans le petit
détail quotidien du regard qu'on ne
croise pas qu'on ne voit pas et qui
pleure qu'est ce que vous pensez des
végétariens
alors les végétariens c'est un monde que
je connais pas je comprends qu'on soit
végétarien c'est un coin bas les gens
qui n'aiment pas la viande il ya des
gens qui ne mangent viande alors qu'ils
en qu'ils aiment ça mais pour des
questions de bilan carbone de souffrance
animale ils ont décidé d'arrêter a
alors
la souffrance animale est intolérable
c'est n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
manger de la viande pas manger de la
viande connaissez la phrase qui est au
dessus du grand manège de l'école de
guerre non on reconnaît le degré
d'évolution d'une société à sa façon de
traiter les animaux a
très bien c'est un sujet je connais bien
est un traître était bien traiter les
animaux
c'est pas
bien traiter les animaux dans les
abattoirs on sait ce qui se passe
va peut-être pu savoir maintenant parce
que ça va être compliqué de faire de
l'investigation de temps avec les
nouvelles lois on est d'accord mais
les animaux
il ya des gens de la ville
qui ont leur poisson rouge chez eux dans
leur aquarium et qui ont une conception
de la vie animale qui est pas conforme à
ce qu'on connaît la campagne oui et vous
parlez du co2 pin up
les khmers verts
qui sont de l'idéologie en absolu qui
font de l'écologie par un fan absolu il
de lui qu
aujourd'hui il accepte de massacrer les
campagnes avec les éoliennes qui sont
hautement polluante je suis prêt à vous
en parler connaît le sujet par coeur
et attendait juste donc on massacre les
campagnes parce que les paysages
criblé d'éoliennes de 100 mètres de haut
avec tous les problèmes sur les animaux
jetant sur les oiseaux cliquer sur
ensuite il accepte la délocalisation
avec le délit écocide cirque aucun
industriel ne va vouloir se réimplanter
en france moi j'ai deux copains qui sont
en chine que dit moi je reviens pas à
cause du délit dit qu'au site parce que
si vous accuser tout le monde de polluer
on
préfère le plus implanté rester là bas
dans les pays qui polluent
ensuite ils disent plus de vaches parce
que c'est à cause de la viande
mais qu'est ce qui va rester de la
campagne est
oui dit sur les éoliennes de continuer
je vais vous dire un mot sur les
éoliennes en fait
personne n'est pour le nucléaire
moi le premier mais simplement tu pas
pour le nucléaire comment pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas pour le nucléaire non mais
sur le principe le nucléaire pour un
problème
c'est les déchets puisque
les déchets dure 24 millions est là
actuellement pas un peu on parle de la
région de but on parle on cherche des
endroits où on peut mettre sous le
granit
plusieurs kilomètres de profondeur les
déchets donc moi ça ça me fait peur et
donc j'ai toujours été circonspect sur
le nucléaire mais j'ai évolué sur la
question c'est un des rares sujets sur
lesquels j'ai vraiment évolué parce que
je me dis mais
nucléaire en fait en co2 c'est moins
polluant que le charbon
est donc c'est même ce qui est moins
polluant beaucoup moins polluant même
que le solaire beaucoup moins pour
l'oncle thermique et
quand on nous dit voilà on va supprimer
le nucléaire et on va et on va faire des
éoliennes dans les éoliennes
elle tourne à côté de chez moi il ya
deux éoliennes je me suis renseigné et
tourne 23 % du temps parce que quand il
ya trop de vent un peu ce pas tourné
comme n'y a pas assez de vent elles
peuvent pas tourner
donc quand elle tourne pas celle
thermique ou le gaz qui prennent qui
prennent le relais et laisser au yen
dans les rotors il ya 17 terres rares
qui viennent de chine
qui sont hautement polluante que
lorsqu'on les extraits
et donc en fait quand on réfléchit on se
dit mais finalement les éoliennes
ans
citons c'est qu'on soit prêts à
massacrer tous les paysages est ce que
c'est vraiment une solution alternative
est est ce que je reproche à ce que
j'appelle les khmers verts sz c'est
l'esprit de système et l'absence de
réflexion et l'absence
l'absence de prudence démonstratif dire
que faut qu'on puisse parler quand même
faut qu'on puisse avoir un avis je vous
donne un exemple la dernière encyclique
du pape oui
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça
le cri de la terre oui
donner la france c'est ce que la france
représente
en pollution au co2 0 9% et la france
représente quelle part de la population
mondiale ah bah non mais ça c'est autre
chose justement mais suède la france 0
9%
il faut absolument que les américains et
les chinois qui représente 45 % de co2
fasse un effort commun et rappelé qu'il
a dit george bush
le train de vie des américains n'est pas
négociable ah ouais
sur l'écologie je te vends
je vais vous dire quelque chose qui va
vous surprendre puisque vous ne
connaissez pas
moi je suis un traumatisé
je suis à traumatiser du rhône en bronze
en
1 jour je sors de chez moi pour aller à
l'école et je vois des chaînes
tricentenaire
ventre à l'air si l'on peut dire
est ce matin là je n'entends plus les
oiseaux ya plus de mésanges et à plus de
chardonnerets je rentre chez moi j'étais
à mon père que ce qui s'est passé que ce
qui se passe il me dit c'est le
remembrement c'est le progrès
pour mon rôle et les ter
et j'ai pu garder ce traumatisme et
quand je suis arrivé à la tête du
conseil général de la vendée en 1988
je me suis aperçu qu'en subventionner
les arrachages de est à la demande de la
fnsea le syndicat agricole dominant
donc j'ai arrêté ça tout de suite
et puis j'ai eu un drame le drame de
l'erika en 1999
et
j'ai découvert que en fait le personnes
et est responsable il y avait un
capitaine indien il y avait une
cargaison de total il y avait une
société de certification italienne etc
les pavillons de complaisance bon et là
en fait
avec les écologistes à l'époque
notamment la ligue pour les oiseaux on a
fait reconnaître par la cour de
cassation au bout de dix ans le
préjudice écologique c'est-à-dire non
plus
avant c'était pollué payeur
c'est à dire que c'est des gens des
charges qui ont nettoyé leurs plages et
on a rétabli le principe pollueur payeur
pour les pour les pour les géants des
mers les les grands temps caire qui
polluent avec leur goudron et après j'ai
vécu une autre expérience un jour il ya
un apiculteur qui arrive dans mon bureau
qui me dit tout ça sans vous êtes comme
tout le monde comme tous les hommes
politiques et il pleurait j'aime et que
si vous arrivez dans le calme et vous
dites moi quoi m'agresser pas à tourner
des jeux perdus tout le mond ial super
du tout mes ruches
et ça fait des années que ça dure que je
crie que je hurle et personne ne
m'écoute gmail ce que moi pourquoi ben
voilà les champs de tournesols c'est à
des miracles prix delphi pronine justice
clej comorien le gaucho et le régent le
site à voilà ils mettent ça c'est des cd
des insecticides systémiques
alors c'est mis dans la plante et puis
après douala et toute façon on a fait un
bayer basf s'est hélas voyez c'est là au
moins c'est pour ça je suis parti dans
ce n'était pas un homme politique comme
les autres je lui dit frank franck a
détruit s'appelle
c'est un type exceptionnel je suis dit
franck on part chez toi tu vas tout
m'expliquer je comprends rien je suis
pas technicien je suis un généraliste
moi je suis à l'intérieur des médias que
le prix de la jupe en chimie c'est ça et
hop il m'a expliqué il m'a fait
rencontrer les plus grands scientifiques
et tout le petit peuple des apiculteurs
qui en fait trouver en moi défenseur
inattendu et je fais un livre qui a été
un boum j'ai été attaqué par bayer pub
et à celle de l'iss s'appelait quand les
abeilles meurent les jours de l'homme
sont comptés stein qui disait ça non
comment sais tu pas il j'étais la phrase
d'einstein exactement et donc
je vous connaissez bien et le mot est
donc en fait j'ai défendu les abeilles
en pension à cette phrase d'einstein
si on a pu la pollinisation des plantes
on va mourir
ils font du notre dame des landes
alors j'ai été en ce qui a fait capoter
le projet
à l'époque bénéficiant de bonnes
relations avec macron laissé passer
plusieurs notes pour lui dire c'est un
projet absurde
c'était avant le coville
c'était un projet absurde parce que
c'était un projet destructeur et
inutile sur le plan
sur le plan de transport aérien quelle
quel regard vous portez sur les
résistants qui étaient sur place
moi je suis un rebelle
donc
j'ai de la sympathie pour les gens qui
résistent
je préfère un résistant
un peu déjanté c'est quoi un peu déjanté
un peu déjanté bas parce que vous
il vaut mieux être un résistant
comment dirais-je
pacifique
déjanté ça veut dire quelqu'un qui sort
de lui-même et qui est la haine du corps
chérif et on s'est donc oui mais je veux
dire non quand je dis un peu déjanté
serre que il ya ils ont été accusés de
vouloir une société complètement
utopique et c'est bon et
mais moi je les ai soutenus dès la
session place non je suis pas allé sur
place
pour une raison simple c'est que
ça aurait été de ma part démagogique
j'avais pas besoin de d'aller sur place
pourquoi pour quémander un petit copain
de popularité un peu un peu comme
darmanin gestation j'ai fait un tout et
tout à l'heure pour dire c'était assez
marrant de voir le
chef
des pyromanes se met au premier rang
entre les pompiers voilà et donc les
hommes politiques qui se promènent à la
recherche d émotion c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours j'ai aussi noté sur
place ils étaient pas déjanté à notre
dame des landes pardon nous on a été à
notre dame des landes ils n'étaient pas
des jantes et ils ont refait société ils
ont refait souid allant des jeux n'est
pas ça non je dis que même un peu
déjanté déjanté ça veut dire un peu à
peu un peu
là pas dans la norme quoi voilà mais
je sais pas si être français
bien sûr mais attendez vous savez que
quand j'étais au parlement européen
un jour il ya l'ascenseur qui s'ouvre
et un mec qui sort de l'ascenseur avec
sa grande moustache et qui me dit toi je
te vois
c'était josé bové
et
j'avais un cancer de l'oeil mélanome de
la choroïde
et j'avais à l'époque des lunettes de
soleil que métier recommandé par
l'institut curie bon depuis j'ai été
guérie par la cdu curie
les mecs de droite passait devant moi
des insulaires
il a plus d embarrasser longtemps
et en fait je l'aimé bien et puis midi
d'abord comment vas tu
je veux savoir
et puis il dit c'est moi je suis un
second
ga bon oui
hélas en fait on parle de l'agriculture
productiviste
et me dit c'est de la folie le
productivisme agrochimiques
je sais que tu es d'accord avec moi je
dis oui d'accord avec toi
et donc
en fait josé bové sur beaucoup de points
essentiels
parce que c'est un homme vrai quoi qu'on
pense par ailleurs de son parcours de ce
qu'il est c'est un
on peut se parler un français en fait un
français
c'est un gaulois réfractaires vous savez
qu'il ya 10 à vouloir être acteur c'est
macron quand il était au danemark il a
dit à la reine du danemark à vous vous
n'êtes pas comme nounou ces dégâts le
gaulois réfractaires il s'est fait
défoncer à l'elysée
comment après s'est fait défoncer à
l'elysée par les gilet jaune oui venez
me chercher voilà voilà mais les jets
les jaunes sont légaux les gaulois
réfractaires et
un gaulois font n'utilisez pas les mots
de quelqu'un d'autre les français des
gilets jaunes sont des français oui oui
mais je veux dire
de gaulle disait cette vieille proposons
gauloise division virtuel donc
un gaulois sa gueule la gauloise et ça
cogne et ce à quoi bon
et
c'est nous on est un peuple sédimenter
salaires on a reçu des couches
successives par nos ancêtres
et on a un petit côté wisigoths d'un
petit côté franc on a un petit côté
bas on commence par être des gaulois et
et dans le tempérament français
né à
quelque chose de créatif
et de bouillants
c'est un peuple créateur et on s'en est
toujours sorti à chaque fois que la
france était dans une impasse le peuvent
foncer sur les sorties parce qu'on est
des résistants et là ce qui nous désole
pendant toute cette période du coc vide
c'est de poser
oui juste avant de se voir un peuple
devenir un peuple légumes
c'est un fait acquis quand on fait peur
à des gaulois normalement il il achetait
la boule de gui et
là tout le monde c'est
joseph josé bové oui ce que je veux dire
dans ma vie moi j'ai rencontré des gens
très différents de moi
et
vers lesquelles je suis allé parce que
par curiosité et viale et qui sont venus
vers moi et voyez par l'ofppt
là il ya quelques heures
on se connaissait pas il en a fait
connaissance au correspondant
avec manuel valls
jeu
est en fait
rencontrer avec la manifestation pour la
police non
non il m'a envoyé un sms
et parce qu'il m'a regardé dans une
émission
voilà c'est un homme ouvert et qui a
sans doute pensé que les urgences
auxquelles il pensait à lui
qui lui paraissait déterminante pour la
survie du pays
étaient les mêmes que celles auxquelles
je pensais moi donc en fait la sq un
train de se passer en france c'est que
c'est la prophétie de soljenitsyne à
jour il m'a dit vous avez des gens
intelligents il pensait à giscard et ses
politiques nick setta et des gens
intelligents fonce dans le métro vous
pouvoir livrer au monde entier ce qui
vous manque c'est un problème c'est une
qualité rare à la qualité dissidente le
courage le courage
et je pense toujours à ce pays andin
dont on disait ce le court à sa complice
est en lui comme la marche ou la
respiration le courage et le courage ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire et vous
savez ce que c'est vous ça veut dire en
fait être un conte ou 4 contre courant
quand il faut riches au lieu de ça il
faut gagner la rive
comme les rameurs en lui tournant le dos
des mois je me suis toujours interrogé
quand tu ne pensais une pensée
m'envahissait je me dis est ce que ce
que je suis pas dans le courant dominant
parce que le courant dominant se trompe
tout le temps
et les français par le gilet jaune sur
leurs gros points il avait le sentiment
que quelque chose ne tourner pas rond
cannes venir sur les ronds points les
écouter oui en vendée
et parler avec eux j'ai connaissez bien
et
oui c'est cette fameuse expression
eu là haut
il nous parle de la fin du monde nous
notre problème c'est la fin du mois
là par exemple
emmanuel macron
je disais tout à l'heure dans le journal
le monde la bande venir un article qui
dit macron prépare sa précampagne
sens paris tous les deux quand vous
voulez qu'on fasse un paris tous les
deux oui je vous par une tournée de
bière qui va pas se présenter ah ben je
parierais pas avec vous puisque je pense
que vous avez raison
alors pourquoi ai je le dirai pas mais
voilà je vous le dise pourquoi il se
présenta pas parce qu'il n'a pas envie
de laisser son nom sali dans l'histoire
parce que le problème est tellement
inextricable qu'il faudra avoir une
sacrée paire pour pouvoir se redresser
les manches et y aller et qu'il n'a pas
envie de laisser son nom genre emmanuel
macron celui qui a laissé tomber la
france
celui qui est qui qui a provoqué
jusqu'au bout le peuple français
oui mais en même temps ça ça pourrait le
conduire à relever le gant justement en
se disant ben je vais faire un
quinquennat de rachat un deuxième
quinquennat de rachat du premier cas été
raté oui moi je pense que
c'est fait
un saut dans l'inconnu donc je peux me
tromper mais je pense que les français
quand ils vont être des bayonnais
quand ils vont quitter la muselière
quand ils vont à décongeler les
décongeler
on va voir les mâchoires serrées et en
fait ils vont
dire à macron
on va faire l'inventaire maintenant tout
ce qui s'est passé à crouy n'est pas
responsable de ça alors il est en grande
partie responsable de ça mais c'est 40
on sait qu'avant alors que l'action de
leur lit coup ils sont resté planqué sur
leurs lauriers
d'accord elle roulait en face d'eux
quand même
il ya des décisions qui ont été prises
on peut ne pas être d'accord mais je
vous les donne moi je pense que le
confinement de masse était une erreur
pourquoi
parce qu'il fallait faire comme au moyen
âge
confiné confiner les mâles portant ne
pas confiner les biens pourtant pour que
la vie continue comment vous faites
quand une maladie avant sournoisement
qu'on peut pas la détecter qu'on n'a pas
les réactifs qu'on n'a pas les tests on
fait quoi
on fait ce que tous les spécialistes ont
dit
c'est
là le sujet était tous d'accord et dé
tous ses 85 ans ces anciens clic et qui
sont les plus frappés et ce sont les
comorbidités
et puis il ya des régions qui sont plus
ou moins frappés on pouvait dès le
départ
faire face
on a fermé la frontière beaucoup trop
tard fermer les frontières beaucoup de
retard et on pouvait faire un
confinement
à la fois c'est cibler géographiquement
on dans l'est et cible est médicalement
sur les publics à rester vous ré ville
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
oui vous aurez vu on n'avait pas été
foutu d'arrêter les correspondances
directes en provenance de wuhan à mâcher
d'accord avec vous alors qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce que vous voulez demander à une
administration
sourde borgne dans le meilleur des cas
de faire du confinement chirurgicale
comme une frappe chirurgicale même si on
s'était fait deux manches enfin mais est
ce que vous dites c'est terrible vous
avez raison mais parce que on dit
souvent c'est moyen âge au confinement
mais en réalité j'ai bien regardé les
historiens du moyenne 9 10 il y avait là
l'ep la psp qu'est ce qu'on fait il y
avait des léproseries y avait des
lazarets pas marseille et à quarantaine
au lazaret de settat serre et donc en
fait c'était très dur d'ailleurs on
enfermait les lépreux ou alors on leur
disait tu vas prendre une crécelle
l'épidémie de peste
marseille oui elle est arrivée comment
alors je les arrivées par le voyage par
des bateaux pour des questions plus ue
et de corruption a chez l'humain oui
on est on n'est pas dépaysé mais
mais parce que là en fait
bon
pourquoi on ne va pas arrêter les vols
de wayne tout de suite pourquoi n'a pas
arrêté les vols de one tout de suite
pour pas froisser la chine pour paf
roissy charles de gaulle parce que parce
que le pouvoir politique est très faible
et que il est sous l'influencé de ceux
qui sont plus puissants que lui qui en
l'occurrence j'imagine
les grandes compagnies et surtout les
les géants qui profitait de cette
situation qui profite le substitut alors
ma les grands profiteurs souhait on dit
chez moi je suis un no 2 avec le vendée
globe je connais bien la côte vendéenne
et par-delà shum oui à baho très fort et
il y avait des profiteurs des paf dans
le temps
et à des profiteurs d'épidémie
qui exulte à l'idée du prochain naufrage
est ce que je raconte dans mon livre
c'est que en fait le président du forum
de davos c'est grave que le d il a écrit
un livre qui s'appelle la grande
réinitialisation du monde
et
c'est lui qui a dit le grand il faut
faire le grand risque est là et la
réinitialisation ci parce qu'on croit la
réinitialiser la réinitialisation du
monde c'est la digitalisation du monde
et
pour faire gagner de l'argent en géant
de numérique et la d il faut que la
pandémie soit je cite une fenêtre
d'opportunité une fenêtre d'opportunité
pourquoi il a dit ça
oui pourquoi il a dit ça
pour que on passe tout en e-commerce et
que en face pour ça avant avant ça dans
son idéologie
pourquoi ils disent
c'est pas c'est pas la vieille rengaine
de la destruction créatrice
ah bah oui alors ça oui je loupe et r
oui mais je suis une terre qui devient
darwin
le score a été
c'est pas la destruction créatrice c'est
la création destructrice et en fait
quand ils ont souhaité il ya eu
un exercice de simulation
d'une pandémie qui ont un avis russe le
18 octobre et sur internet vous pourrez
comme il en existe pour le terrorisme
comme il en existe pour les catastrophes
de d'inondations très bonne ouïe très
très bonne réflexion sauf que
mon cher sky
sauf que
ce sont les puissances privées corp
gagné c'était grassi de simulation sont
pas les états et ça ça me gêne parce que
c'est johnson & johnson c'est microsoft
c'est bill gates une fondation c'est le
forum de davos est un voilà que les
états seront délégués en quelque sorte
pouvoir
qui est précieux pour eux de faire des
simulations d'état de l'appui sans quoi
ils font ça les états a largement
parce que leur classe leur classe de
fonctionnaires de haut fonctionnaire
soit disant aux manettes
cc ans ils se sont en partie absolument
et il c'est devenu un état dans l'état
exactement c'est y survivent qui
survivent à chaque mandature ouais je
vais à comprendre je comprends qu'on des
lego privé à l'attendait quand on est
pas foutu de faire une langue
l'inventaire d'un stock de masques oui
mais
il ya des domaines régaliens qui peuvent
pas être déléguées au privé parce que
sinon le privé la puissance privée
devient supérieure à la puissance
publique et la puissance privée n'a pas
pour vocation de défendre le bien commun
il en est où la puissance publique
française et l'onu où la puissance
publique française
là par exemple
on a délégué notre souveraineté
militaire à l'otan on a délégué notre
souveraineté numérique aux cafards on a
délégué notre souveraineté
pharmaceutique à la chine puisque 80%
des principes actifs
sont sont fait ailleurs et on découvre
que quand on est nu
eh bien
on est impuissant et on dépense et on
dépend des autres si votre génération
qui a laissé faire oui mais là là sera
faire des géants du numérique là ce que
je vais vous dire parce que j'ai vécu je
vais vous résumer en deux phrases ce que
moi j'ai vécu depuis depuis depuis
maastricht et l'organisation mondiale du
commerce et la chute du mur de berlin
en fait il y avait des gens
je pèse chacun de mes mots il y avait
des gens des élites globalisé comme
dirait chevènement qui
pensaient à un monde unifié un monde
sans cloisons un monde sans frontières
les uns
par souci d eau logique de l'état les de
la fraternité cosmique dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure les autres pour
créer un grand marché planétaire de
masse et gagner de plus en plus d'argent
ces gens-là savez je les ai entendus et
je leur ai dit et jimmy goldsmith qui
était mon colistier en 1994 94 aux
élections européennes disait mais
c'était un esprit brillant universel et
le prix nobel d'économie maurice allais
disait attention quand vous mettez 5
milliard de personnes dans la même pièce
un seul microbes renvoie tout le monde
au tapis et donc ils savaient ces gens
c'est pour ça qu'ils faisaient des
exercices de simulation
que ce monde là sans cloisons serait
hautement pathogène il le savait et s'y
préparer et pourquoi et s'y préparer
parce que c'était pas perdu pour tout le
monde cette fameuse fenêtre
d'opportunité c'est ce qui a permis aux
géants du numérique de prospérer
ce sont eux qui se sont enrichis et
qu'est-ce qui sont offertes par dont ils
ont saisi l'opportunité
ils ont saisi l'opportunité et le passé
quoi puis ont saisi des opportunités
plus on a d'opportunités plus absolument
et la soul et le jour d'après ce que
j'appelle le jour d'après
on peut le qualifier deux fois
la classe dirigeante est faible et quand
un pouvoir est faible
quand on lui propose le contrôle total
avec l'inspection du sort intime grâce
aux algorithmes c'est tout bénef et
deuxièmement la big tech
l'automatisation
l'intelligence artificielle
l'idée c'est la numérisation de nos vies
avec deux conséquences
premièrement la suppression de la classe
moyenne et deuxièmement la suppression
de la société de voisinage la
suppression des métiers de la main et du
coeur
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
pourquoi les restaurants et bistrots
ouvrant dernier elle parce que c'est
tous les lieux de convivialité
pose une question avant de vous laisser
continuer est ce que je voulais juste
terminée parce que dans l'exercice de
simulation il parle déjà d essentiel des
non essentiels
vs sky et donc et sur le 18 octobre 2019
bien avant le cobp id ça veut dire que
déjà et pense que ils vont profiter de
la circonstance que je des très graves
pour euthanasier les non essentiels
énoncés anciens c'est tous les
indépendants
et donc en fait ça rappelle wells
time machine qui disait il ya les
morlock
et les héloïse les morlocks sont sous
terre
à force de l'enfant et les volants voilà
bon voilà et vous connaissez un petit
peu l' architecture du renseignement
américain non est ce que vous connaissez
alors l'architecturé des gaffes
à aller la prendra quelques jours je
vous pose la question on retrouve
toujours la puissance publique
américaine ou sein de leurs pointes de
diamant numérique
vous le savez oui donc peut-être que les
gaffes à google facebook amazon sont
aussi la pointe de diamant du
renseignement américain et que derrière
leur côté nous sommes ultra privé
peut-être aussi je dis bien peut-être
c'est aussi l'état américain la
puissance publique américaine comment la
france s'organise dans ce ce climat de
guerre économique alors est-ce que les
licornes bisounours de votre ami macron
un mandat mais ma compte c'est votre ami
d'un chrono elle a calé avant lui il a
fait jouer on va parler de la méme
accroc après on va parler des slaloms et
là vous menez c'est un problème
essentiel
et les gens qui nous regardent faut
qu'ils comprennent la chose suivante
c'est que ça que moi j'ai découvert ce
que je connais pas bien ce monde là mais
des fameuses algorithmes
en fait par les algorithmes vous pouvez
pas prédictifs non seulement ça mais
vous pouvez
connaître
mes goûts
non sexuel votre idiotie voilà tuto
et dans mon livre je dis déjà regardé du
port d'où tu à internet non merde alors
vous connaissez pas ça non vous utilisez
quel moteur de recherche non mais moi je
connais pas tout ça parce que c'est pas
mon monde mais moi j'ai un portable
c'est elle que ma grand-mère et voilà
parce que tu m'as grand mais incapable
d'en c'est pourquoi je le seul à
apporter à bach ap c'est pourquoi
pour être tranquille
et tranquille de quoi mais bon est belle
parce que sap pour m'écouter c'est plus
difficile ça c'est une vue d'esprit m'a
mis à bas je sais pas en tout cas j'ai
l'impression que je suis plus tranquille
et voilà mais mais par contre ce que ce
que j'ai compris c'est que en fait vous
avez le gendarme et le mouchard
je parle sous votre contrôle se
connaissent et se montrent beaucoup
mieux que moi le contrôle de ma
communauté alors attendez
le gendarme c'est celui qui dit c'est
les pouvoirs publics aux mouchards
je vous donne la liberté toute liberté
d'aller chez les gens et de les plus
tard d'aller jusqu'aux zones cérébrales
puisque on parle des implants cérébraux
pour pouvoir lire les ondes cérébrales
parce que google le prochain article
c'est l'éternité donc de l'homme
augmente et c'est un nom qui vont aller
très loin
et donc le gendarme se disent quand même
génial les algorithmes s'éteint donc les
géants du numérique son passé un accord
avec eux au passage si un type ne plaît
pas on lui coupe le tweet
ça veut dire qu'en cette année le pitch
menthe numérique
que je parle et le bouchard lui dit aux
gendarmes pas de problème je t'amène
tout ce que tu veux tu veux de l'info
sur sky je vais te donner d'infos sur
sky que d'infos sur philippe de villiers
j'ai tout donné
d'où le passeport sanitaire parce que le
passeport sanitaires préparent ce que
l'onu appelait l'identité numérique il
ya un groupe américain et là je vous
rejoins un un groupe de pression
extrêmement important un consortium avec
microsoft avec la fondation
avec eux évidemment on retrouve bill
gates mais aussi d'autres gens très
puissants et ce consortium pousse à
l'identité numérique et c'est quoi
l'identité numérique elle est déjà
pratiqué au malawi et au kenya avec le
passeport vaccinal sous cutanée c'est à
dire le carnet de vaccins a sion une
puce ici un article du monde le 19
décembre
2019 salut bill gates qui a réussi à
installer ce système
le problème de ce système
on sait ce qui se passe en chine avec le
système du crédit social c'est que une
fois que vous êtes poussez vous êtes
contrôlés vous est géolocalisé vous êtes
inspectés et à terme vous appartenez à
la puissance publique qui est derrière
les géants du numérique et donc ça pue
le capitalisme de surveillance pardon
c'est ce que vous appelez le capitalisme
de surveillants exactement pour vous
n'êtes pas le seul à appeler ça comme ça
ah non c'est pas une expression de moi
mais le capitalisme de surveillance
c'est une mutation
du c'est nécessaire comment est-ce que
c'est pas nécessaire
je me fais l'avocat du diable alors le
capitaine de surveillance
quand vous voyez attendent et répond à
ses bons tours auparavant
quand vous voyez des mouvements radicaux
religieux
qu'on vous voyez une population qui
s'énerve je me fais l'avocat du diable
mais je vois bien
comment quand votre élevage de poulets
commencent à dégénérer
l'image le métaphone c'est assez
justesse que l'inertie qu'on a prise
nécessite des mesures de ce type là
parce qu'on va pas pouvoir traiter ça à
la main alors je vous réponds
la grandeur du politique c'est le
régalien le régalien c'est la sécurité
lord la justice et à la souveraineté
quand vous n'avez plus la souveraineté
comme vous n'avez plus le régalien il
vous reste que le capitalisme de
surveillance s'est confié à des privés
le soin de faire ce que vous n'êtes plus
capables de faire je vous adore et est
donc et quand vous confier à des privés
il est surveillé par votre état alors je
pense je préfère l'ordre la sécurité la
souveraineté d'un état nation
démocratique
quand on démocratie en france alors non
on n'y est plus
je vais jusqu'au bout de mon
raisonnement est apprécié on prend ça
parce que c'est très important votre
question est capital donc capitalisme de
surveillance ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'en fait
moi je suis pour le capitalisme
je suis pour le capitalisme
parce que ils créent les richesses c'est
pas le socialisme c'est pas le
collectivisme je fais
et je pense qu'il n'y a pas de valeur
sans valeur ajoutée scellier est donc
vous appelez richesses alors pas ce que
j'appelle richesse c'est
quelque chose qui nous permet de
survivre quelque chose qui nous permet
de progresser vraiment je n'appelle pas
richesse qui détruisent qui polluent je
suis pour le bien national brut et non
pas le produit national brut
les pots d'échappement ça pollue ses
comptes et dans la croissance mans donc
il faut une croissance
revisitée par le bon sens le capitalisme
surveillance détruit le capitalisme
davos ils ont mis au point des
des maps des transformations maps
pour inciter les entreprises à prendre
des chartes éthiques et alors dans ces
chartes éthiques il ya des mots comme
inclusion et quittez donc c'est là c'est
donc l'entreprise
n'est plus là pour être au service d'une
clientèle est là pour être au service
d'une idéologie ça ça va détruire le
capitalisme le capitalisme de
surveillance qui dont le produit
principal et l'intrusion dans le forez
intime c'est la capitalisme destructeur
et d'ailleurs le capitalisme de
surveillance se méfie de lui-même c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont conclu un compromis
historique avec des écolos en faisant
croire aux échos que quand tu numérise
tulle des carbone
alors que c'est complètement faux les
datacenter faut lui une fois il n'y plus
que l'aviation civile mais les écolos
crois ça donc restez chez vous numérisés
comme ça vous décarbonés donc le
capitalisme de surveillance je n'en veux
pas et vous parlez du christianisme tout
à l'heure il ya eu des encycliques au
19e siècle disons que le capitalisme
libéral c'est le renard libre dans le
poulailler libre alors maintenant je
serais pour être question est ce qu'on
est en démocratie
non on est en oligarchie
le
la souveraineté et la souveraineté
externe souveraineté interne la
souveraineté externe et là entre les
mains des commissaires de l'otan et
c'est aller à l'extérieur et nous
appartient plus donc en fait le
président macron comme ses prédécesseurs
et moulinet
diplomatie reçoit présidents africains
mais c'est c'est la diplomatie c'est du
verbe le pouvoir est ailleurs mais on ne
dit pas en français ou pouvoir le
pouvoir il est alors qui n'est pas bien
selon moi il est un bout à bruxelles les
commissaires qui font les lois sont les
transpose après un bond à francfort la
monnaie un bout à washington sheila que
décide la diplomatie française
et maintenant des petits bouts un peu
partout par exemple vous parliez très
bien sky tout ça leur avait fait
allusion aux turcs vous rendez compte
qu'on paye un pourboire de 6 milliards
d'euros à
erdogan
pour qu'ils gardent nos migrants quelque
sorte de faille garde les migrants qui
viennent de serré migron alors et donc
ceux qui sont prêts à venir chez nous et
donc on leur décès merkel qu'à traiter
ça avec macron à seynod migreront parce
qu on a foutu bordel dans leur pays
parce qu'on a un capitalisme qui détruit
leur économie à la bien sûr et donc on
doit les assumer ah ben on ne sait pas
question le problème c'est que on peut
peut-être faire autrement et peut-être
arrêter la migration
qui va qui est en train de nous
submerger tête et arrêter de faire lire
partout nous et arrêter de faire les
gars partout les guerres inutiles oui
mais vous savez c'est marrant parce que
là c'est pas bon non non non mais c'est
une expression c'est
vous fait penser à la
tribune des militaires en fait on a
envoyé des militaires au mali en
afghanistan en centrafrique je suis pas
sûr que ce soit très utile ils ont
découvert l'islamisme et quand ils sont
venus en france ils ont dit c'est
marrant parce que là c'est marrant car
non seulement on ne vous plaît pas vous
avez raison c'est terrible parce qu'en
fait
chez nous on combat pas tellement
l'islamisme dans les quartiers sensibles
on nous envoie là-bas c'est l'épreuve du
feu
dans des pays où c'est pas notre
problème quoi mais est donc pas compris
qu'il y avait des puissances étrangères
qui se déployait en afrique et que
peut-être la france n'était pas très
très chaude pour laisser la chine la
russie
s'implanter d'une façon durable oui
d'accord mais
alors si vous aborder ce sujet là je
vais vous dire
le
aujourd'hui l'europe
elle nous impose des choix qui sont pas
les nôtres qui ne devraient pas être les
nôtres
par exemple
nous
on devrait pratiquer la phrase de de
gaulle
l'europe de l'atlantique à l'oural
pourquoi on est fâché avec les russes
ils sont européens que nous c'est qui si
l'on y réfléchit mais la france c'est à
dire en fait d'eux les gouvernements
français depuis un certain nombre
d'années
on considère que poutine c'est le diable
et donc ont pratiqué une politique de
sanctions à l'initiative de l'amérique
notre maître
bollwiller ils disent elles à
l'europe le rêve d'être gouvernés par
une commission américaine mais je prends
d'autres exemples
l'allemagne elle
elle est fâchée avec la russie mais elle
installe cohen d'un stream de serques
and oléoduc dire que son gaz s'arranger
avec les russes
donc nous on est
on aller baiser l'histoire quoi
sert qu en fait on regarde les allemands
qui s'entendent avec taurus les
allemands plutôt qu'aux cullin comment
mais plutôt qu'au cul oui oui sinon les
allemands qui s'entendent avec les
chinois et nous on fait un
on brandit l'évangile des droits de
l'homme avec les chinois de gaulle
disait très bien la france ne traite
qu'avec les étapes avec les régimes donc
en fait les chinois en fait
je connais ça très bien
parlé parlé la relation que j'ai avec
eux que les chinois le crédit social et
je vous en passe non d'accord mais si on
veut faire la morale à l'humanité sky on
va on va s'enfermer vous chez vous et
moi chez moi et puis c'est bon donc en
fait si on confond la politique et la
morale dans ce cas là on vit plus bonds
est bon donc les chinois en fait
je vais vous dire il attend de la france
il aime la france parce que voile pour
pour eux la france et la culture
occidentale ils veulent pas de
l'amérique qui veulent pas être ils
veulent pas de la disney cratie ils
veulent pas être coquin colonisé bon et
donc nous c'est une chance pour nous
un peu plus fou et en chine souvent le
dya bon puis franchise bah oui et je
peux vous dire qu'on est reçu comme des
amis voilà donc en fait la france
elle et elle est regardée dans le monde
dans le monde entier
avec un regard énamouré et on n'en
profite pas et donc loeb qu'il faudrait
faire aujourd'hui c'est la grande europe
confédérale avec la russie avec
l'angleterre
le l'angleterre il sera d'accord pour
faire une grande confédéral à condition
de rester souverains et comme nous on
n'est plus souverain
on a donné tout le pouvoir mais sur la
souveraineté je voudrais ajouter un mot
mitterrand un jour on m'a dit
ça je m'en souviens très bien c'était à
florence et new savez on parlait des de
la justice des juges et des de gaulle
avait raison
il ya qu'une cour suprême c'est le
peuple et c'est une manière de répondre
à votre question est aujourd'hui et à 5
cour suprême et la cour de cassation et
du conseil d'état et la cour
le la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
ea le conseil constitutionnel et la cour
de justice il ya cinq cour suprême est
en fait il s'en donne à coeur joie les
juges c'est les parlements d'ancien
régime quand lui 16
rapatriés par les parlements que mon
pouls avait dissous c'est la fin
pourquoi parce que quand vous laissez un
juge
juger sans appliquer la loi du peuple
mais en appliquant sa propre loi sert
son idéologie
à ce moment là il ya plus d'une nation
possible les juges les cours suprêmes
par deux considère que le principe de
fraternité
le principe de discrimination
sont des principes supérieurs aux
principes
de la souveraineté nationale et donc ils
détricotent les nations européennes et
les met à leurs bottes sur la chine au
hockey comment vous pouvez faire du
business avec une nation qui est un
comportement belliqueux envers nous qui
fait du renseignement invasif sur notre
territoire
qui envoie ses hirondelles à côté de
l'île longue vous connaissez cette
histoire comment on peut faire du
business avec quelqu'un qui nous là mais
par derrière
alors je vous réponds
un jour
un grand
patron m'a dit
quand on est dans la jungle
il vaut mieux être un lion qu'une
gazelle les tripes à l'air
j'ai pourquoi vous dites ça dit c'est le
principe du commerce
d'efforts ne respecte que l'effort quand
ils sont plus forts
et donc faut être plus fort
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si on revenait un pays souverain et
je vous dis après comment c'est possible
à mon avis avec mon expérience puisque
tu as un entrepreneur créateur
si on revenait à pays souverain
on serait respectée si on revenait à
payer souverain super répondu demain je
reviens je veux rebondir sur ce que vous
ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai pas répondu
terre
ben merde main on à la souveraineté
numérique parce que c'est pas thierry
breton s'est pas l'europe qui va faire
la souveraineté numérique je pense que
le clos de microsoft mais voilà
donc
puisqu'il ya une tech française sedar
mais ça c'est la priorité des priorités
c'est
aussi urgent que le téléphone dans les
années 50 c'est à dire reprendre notre
souveraineté numérique alors autant non
c'est pas trop tard
c'est presque trop tard
vous faites peut-être allusion à ce qui
se passe en ce moment c'est reculer il
ya une bataille entre et le masquer
j'aime bezos ce
qu'ils veulent installer 42000 satellite
42000 satellites en orbite basse et
entre 500 km et 1200 km et
il semblerait que l'ong 42000 satellite
bon il semblerait qu'il reste quelques
fréquences
que fait la france que fait l'europe les
câbles elles cassent des trottoirs
jardin tirent des câbles elles cassent
des trottoirs je me rappelle du dos
d'une conférence où j'étais avec trois
potes à coeur et on les écoute et ça
devienne une dizaine d'années c'était
juste à côté du cnes et il nous
expliquait qu'il fallait casser des
trottoirs est tiré d car il oui pourquoi
parce que marchés publics qui dit marché
public votre ami charles pasqua côté
mieux que nous sa graisse un peu la
patte partout ça va et travailler les
gens ouais donc ça fait de la
subornation vote oui donc plutôt que
d'envoyer des satellites et faire la
nique à une messe qu on a préféré casser
des trottoirs voilà c'est magnifique ah
ben c'est exactement ça ben qu'est ce
qu'on fait ayez un autre principe mais
un autre principe
c'est la loi de la concurrence
en europe c'est à dire qu'en fait dès
qu'il ya des cons est sur le point de
faire un grand groupe européen à
bruxelles dit non la loi de la
concurrence est impossible donc en fait
on a perdu tous nos nouveaux fleurons
alors moi je vais vous dire pourquoi
ça ça va peut-être vous étonner
en fait quand j'ai créé depuis du fou
je n'avais pas l'argent
pas un centime
et il y avait les géants les mastodontes
disent n'être c'est un cirque du soleil
à l'époque tout ça
donc aucune chance
et tout le monde faisait aucune chance
bonhomme et tout le monde se foutait de
ma gueule
et en fait j'ai découvert quelque chose
c'est qu'on n'est plus autant tous ces
gens résonnait comme on raisonne tous
autant comment si on l'était autant de
vidal de la blache et de ford c'est un
vidal de la blache c'est ce géographe
qu'ils aient la france est grande
regardez les petits points drôles de
petits poireaux sur la mappemonde la
france est grande
et vous trouver enfin parce qu'elle a
beaucoup de territoires parce que c'est
l empire mais en fait
le aujourd'hui
on vit
et le nucléaire en est un exemple à
thomond exemple la combinaison
contradictoires de l'infiniment petit à
l'infiniment en puissant
qui fait que par une start up
qui fait que vous barber avec peu de
moyens réussi ce que j'ai réussi
en d'autres termes aujourd'hui une
start-up une petite entreprise
et le produit est singulier
et qui à la détermination et
d'intelligence et l'imagination écouter
des croupières très très vite et met par
terre
un géant aux pieds d'argile
aujourd'hui une petite nation
à autre matière grise
et à imaginaire c'est con elle peut s'en
sortir et on le voit bien il ya des pays
en fait qui sont des pays regardez
comment un pays comme les etats unis une
puissance déclinante
et confondent la taille et la puissance
à un moment donné vous êtes trop
puissant vous avez une taille trop
grande et vous finissez par devenir un
puissant le là on voit bien que
l'économie du futur aménage une place
qui va être de plus en plus importante
à celui qui est petit qui se meut
faciles manqués mobile
d'abord intellectuellement et qui peut
tailler des croupières aux plus grands
alors j y pense et l'expérience de ma
ville vous voulez faire et rage il parle
d'entrepreneurs entrepreneurs de
start-up heures
oui au preneur comment vous voulez être
agile avec vous les connaissez bien des
felynes à sciences po ces gens qui
s'estiment que comme leur niveau
d'études des
dépenses est vrai quand quand on voit
monsieur marc monsieur chine monsieur
monsieur
j'ai retrouvé mort
le chinois qui a qui s'est retrouvé
enfermé là parce que le parti n'était
pas très content il part de rien comment
nous les français voulaient être agile
jeu je pense à un mes amis jean-pierre
bykov et je lui passe le bonjour
d'ailleurs
comment vous voulez être agile avec avec
notre caste d'élite qui ne rêve que
d'une chose c'est de prendre leur
retraite ferr continuer le ronron
quotidien
héééé et que ça passe tout doucement que
comme vous fait vous voyez les
entrepreneurs
alors
la france en fait donc je prends lorsque
ce que je dit je vais même plus loin et
après je pense que la réponse ma réponse
personnelle tiré de mon expérience ce
que moi j'ai une double expérience où l
entreprise donc je comprends très bien
ce que vous dites puisque
une entreprise aujourd'hui accablé
n'importe pas produit un bon
pour pour produire faut avoir un cadre
juridique fixe avoir envie de produire
je ne peux pas vous laisser accabler
d'impôts c'est normal depuis des impôts
il faut être fier de la concurrence
mécontent voit une infirmière à me
sanson balouet maintenant et bien sûr
méchant j'arrive là quand
quand j'étais sous préfet de vendôme
il y avait jusqu'à dans mon
arrondissement et donc le prix dans la
république à l'époque jusqu'à venait
dans sa propriété de ton
et ma vie c'est
parce qu'ils aient vous êtes un capteur
parce que je lisais franchement les
choses ce que j'entendais sur le marché
le vendôme et c'est pas folichon
et donc j'étais un capteur pour lui et
donc qu'il ne parlait et un jour il m'a
dit cette source d'extraordinaire il m'a
dit cher vieux api devient socialiste
à 40 % de prélèvements
il en est à combien il en est à 39
40 % de prélèvements c'est à dire 40 %
de prélèvements ça veut dire jusqu'au
mois de mai vous travaillez pour l'état
il fluidifié pardon il faut être fier
oui la france les du lien les services
publics oui absolument mais simplement
un pays moderne un pays
un pays efficace simple et
riche qui développe la richesse il faut
qu'il y ait un équilibre
entre la sphère publique et la sphère
privée et donc qui me dit 40% bon à la
fin de son quinquennat de son septennat
on était à 43 44
et depuis
le chiffre empire et avec l'argent
magique
pour reprendre l'expression de macron
avec le pg e que l'économie sous
perfusion
si on compare la france avec le
socialiste des plus belles années de ma
vie on n'est pas très loin c'est à dire
qui à un moment donné c'est la succise
bon et
c'est terrible ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui parce que en fait le
régalien est en faillite ce qui devrait
concentrer les
la force de frappe de l'impôt ce pour
quoi
on a délégué notre instinct justicier
par la justice quand elle est en panne
quand vous voyez viry-châtillon mérignac
sa halimi vous dites moi c'est ça
fonctionne plus bon pas et
donc nous justicier notre instinct de la
justice dans les temps barbares en
exercer nous-mêmes de communauté à
communauté
maintenant le dga délègue à l'état donc
le régalien fonctionne plus la justice
est dévoyée l'état est défaillant
il ya des territoires qui sont plus en
france chez nous bon donc c'est une
catastrophe le régalien
il n'y a pas d'argent pour le régalien
pas assez d'argent les policiers tout à
l'heure me disait
on a dû parfois vous arrêter sur
l'histoire des policiers oui parce que
oui longtemps ya pas d'argent sur le
gallia bernos cahiers et est
par contre
et on accable entre les entrepreneurs et
notamment ceux qui veulent créer cercle
décourager de créer en france
contrairement à certains pays et puis
surtout on a décidé de liquider notre
industrie qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
peut être la puissance d'un pays sur
l'industrie voilà donc je vais
lui ai même parlé de la police
donc la police
qu'est ce qui se passe etc la police il
ya les notes d'admission sait combien
ces 5 ou 7 sur 20 c'est ça pour rentrer
dans la police nationale
gross et du ramassage scolaire parce que
bon il faudrait de la chair à canon
après on s'étonne que ils tirent en
manifestation dix ans à voter en se
marrant quand ils mettent des headshots
dents sur la gilet jaune
on s'étonne qui falsifient des preuves
dans certains procès où il faut trouver
des coupables
c'est le même c'est le même principe qui
s'est passé avec l'effondrement de l'ex
union soviétique
des policiers soient corrompus soient
pas très futé je ne fais pas de
généralités
qui travaillent dans des commissariats
où ça sent la pisse
où ils se font insulter et cracher
dessus
l'état fait quoi on se retrouve avec une
population française qui est fâché avec
sa police
et a raison
pourquoi non est-ce que vous avez vu les
plaies de guerre sur les gilet jaune oui
mais on peut pas dire que là
que le peuple français soit fâché avec
sa police je crois quand même qu'il
partie de sa police oui mais c'est
bizarre parce que le peuple français pas
du tout fâché de son armée oui et pas du
tout fâché avec sa gendarmerie
exactement bah alors qu'ici se passe bah
non avec la police tout fâché avec ses
pompiers ou un parent quelques crétins
qui leur balance des machines avaient
tous deux sur sur la gueule
comment ça se fait qu'une partie de la
population soit fâché que sa police
alors moi je pense que
le
skill démoralise la police
fait que
ces deux choses d'abord on sait plus ce
qu'on défend
défend la france ou quoi
mais il prononce plus le mot france les
et globalisé
on défend un imaginaire collectif ou
quoi ou un pays complètement facture est
fragmentée où chacun vit dans son coin
où il appuie la notion de la communauté
nationale donc quand vous êtes policier
vous défendez quelque chose de plus
grand que vous donc là il ya un vrai
problème c'était la police à votre
époque oui mais non fait policiers pour
en voir là le salaire vais
tranquillement pop pop pop je peux vous
dire que les gens que j'ai vu cet après
midi
sur critique pour les manifestants alors
les gens j'avais vraiment j'ai vu parler
avec beaucoup de temps vous n'aviez pas
de masques dans la rue c 135 balle
j'ai mis mon masque moment des discours
je n'ai pas mis parce qu'il pleuvait
comme vache qui pisse
et je suis hostile au principe du masque
en plein air parce que moi je sais que
dans quelques mois on dira et vous serez
le premier à dire s'est fait avoir je
peux pas croire que vous attendez vous
êtes au courant de ce qui se passe et
que le vario dire
non mais en plein air il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques qui explique que le masque
est inutile voilà et moi je le crois je
pense que je jeu par mon expérience
personnelle
le
quand on est en plein air c'est votre
expérience personnelle si vous étiez
spécialisée dans les maladies
infectieuses et tropicales on aurait pu
discuter vous êtes entrepreneur oui
d'accord oui donc attention pas et moi
j'ai reçu l'année dernière beaucoup de
monde au puy du fou et il n'y a pas eu
de problème puisqu'on est en plein air
donc c'est très différent si tu dis les
études et sur la clause à coeur joie
quand on se voit et sincèrement ça a été
monitorer comment ça vous avez reçu du
monde est-ce que vous est ce que les
gens vont laisser leur numéro de
téléphone est ce que vous étiez en
contact les clients à pattes et après le
problème c'est tout sinon on l'aurait su
croyez moi mais sur la police que je
voulais dire ce que les policiers se
sentent pas soutenus c'est tout il se
sent qu'elle fasse le ménage dans leurs
rangs quand on voit des gamins parce que
c'est bien certain c'est des gamins qui
se comportent n'importe comment qui
parle n'importe comment qui savaient pas
remplir un je vais être vulgaire un
[__] de procès verbal sans faire plus
de fautes ce cas qu'un gamin de co2
quand on voit quand on voit des ddd
certains dans les manifestations se
comporter mais c'est n'importe quoi
et où on les paye ont les armes et a
pris cet homme c'est toi que que ça
souffle vous prépare général je vais pas
jean errecart pourquoi pourquoi les
gendarmes sont plus respectés pourquoi
une journée plus rapide d'un militaire
est plus respectée alors les gendarmes
sont plus respectés parce que ils ont
pas les mêmes tâches gendarmes sont
plutôt au milieu rural alors que les
policiers ce qu'on en voit dans les
quartiers impossible quartier impossible
au milieu rural oui mais moins les
gendarmes sont moins exposées dans la
situation actuelle que les policiers et
moi ce que je vais vous dire c'est de
formation alors bien sûr mais d'abord
d'abord il ya la société
il ya de défaillance en amont en aval et
en amont et plus d'autorité nulle part
le principe mais deux ans et s'est
effondré par tous donc des gamins
ne ressentent plus le principe de
l'autorité ça parce que c'est
et deuxièmement en amont en aval pardon
et à plus la sanction
donc une société les policiers quand ils
quand ils font des conneries oui ce
couvre feu dans les coins c'est si la
sanction par exemple par exemple la
sanction pénale
aujourd'hui les juges
ont la culture de l'excusé
c'est à dire que
dupont moretti par exemple a expliqué
qu'il serait le ministre des détenus et
pour être mises aussi des victimes est
en fait
la justice est laxiste
donc ça démoralise les policiers
pourquoi puisque aussitôt
menotté aussitôt libéré non mais il faut
faire que plus de places de prison il
faut faire un modèle à la suédoise c'est
à dire avoir des plis des prisons qui
réellement rééduque les jo ou permettent
aux gens de se reconstruire il faut
il ya la chaîne pénale ce qu'on appelle
la chaîne pénale
et devrait être élargi à la chaîne de la
vie donc la première chose à faire
c'est de sortir l'école de la faillite
parce que ce que vous venez de dire là
depuis cinq minutes en fait c'est
l'école
et
au lieu de s'occuper de l'écriture
inclusive
on ferait mieux
de d'apprendre aux enfants de france
les rudiments de la vie en société ce
qui formait que l'uniforme dans les
écoles oui et ce qu'il faut remettre le
fait que quand un professeur ou un
adulte rentrent dans une pièce il faut
se lever absolument à l'ancienne oui à
l'ancienne
le
jeu vous raconter une une histoire de
l'histoire en 1870
il ya eu l'effondrement de la france
la défaite de sedan
donc on perd la guerre c'est un
traumatisme immense les grands
républicains de l'époque
les fameux jules jules qui sera cette
appli plus tard note le français car ils
disent
il ya un problème il ya plus de
fédérateur c'est pour ça que la france
est faible
il faut qu'on trouve un fédérateur
un fédérateur de substitution saint
chrême de l'ancien régime parce qu'il
faut quelque chose de sacré pour que les
français puissent avoir le feu sacré et
là ils inventent ernest lavisse
l'instituteur nationale comme on
l'appelait
invente le roman national serre qu'il
dit
ça suffira pas
d'assurer les voisinages celui que
d'imposer des règles il faut il faut une
romance la propagande non il faut un
roman d'amour oui ça c'est pas la
propagande je vous provoque oui
si moi je vous dis vous aimez votre
famille il veut me dit oui vous avez des
souvenirs oui ce que j'ai oublié ceux
qui sont venus jusqu'à moi et vous y
êtes attaché à oui je l'aurais bien tout
savoir c'est ça une nation en fait une
nation c'est un drame moral
et
dans une nation
y aller parce que vous auriez préféré de
tournai qui s'impose à vous qui sont des
pages de acheter mais il ya aussi des
pages de grandeur si vous pratiquez en
permanence
l'amnésie des vi nations oui l'amnésie
des grandeurs et l'hyper président l
acheter ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui à
l'école à commencer par l'école bah
c'est foutu et donc tant d'idées l'hyper
des idées acheté à l'école oui qu'est ce
que vous entendez par ça c'est simple
la france
est un peuple de mutins en 14 de
collabos en 40 le terrorisme en algérie
est d'ailleurs la colonisation a été un
crime contre l'humanité a déclaré vous
promouvez on va le reprendre mais il y
avait comme une pourcentage de
résistance en france alors là
alors parlons ça parce que je me suis
suffisent d'un d'un homme qui a eu là
que la croix du combattant volontaire de
la résistance qu'elle était un héros de
sens qu'à terminer sa guerre à lübeck
aucun don panoz de lübeck donc c'est
vraiment un sujet que je connais bien et
c'est drôle ce que vous dites parce que
j'ai repensé à ça avec la tribune des
militaires qui ont été traités de
factieux par
la ministre désormais et ça m'a rappelé
que mon père me disait mon père disait
tu sais en 40 philippe
résiste on était premiers résistants
étaient traités de factieux par les
collabos bon
je répondre à votre question ce qui
compte dans la vie d'un peuple comme
dans la vie d'une famille
comme dans la ville une communauté
c'est la manière de sortir par le haut
et donc
soit on considère que la vie est un
tissu de noirceur et entretiens que les
noirceurs et le roman national devient
un roman noir et à ce moment là on a en
horreur le pays dans lequel on est et on
n'a surtout pas envie de ressembler à ce
qu'ils sont et on a plutôt envie de
garder sa propre civilisation sur le sol
on est arrivé et ce soir les apps une
nation je vous coupe
c'est aussi important de rappeler à
notre jeune génération
qui a vidé [__] de collabos en 40 ans
en france pour éviter que ça nous
retombe sur la gueule
je vous réponds
il ya deux
niveaux différentes
pour la vérité d'un peuple dans le temps
long il ya
tout ce qui concerne la conversation
savantes
et d'être important qui est des médecins
légistes les historiens qui
n'hésite pas à gratter de calabre
pour détecter les poches
de pourrissement
parce que une nation qui ne vivent pas
dans la vérité de son histoire
elle ne peut pas vivre dans la sérénité
mais le deuxième niveau est différent et
c'est là que la politique arrive vous
pouvez pas faire vivre un peuple qui ne
cultivent que c'est la
ftc tenté que
il est vécu d'autres choses que de la
lâcheté
ce qui fait que le peuple français est
encore là c'est que dans la chaîne des
comptines des continuités et
discontinuités
il ya eu de la grandeur
napoléon c'est plein de conneries
comment il a fait beaucoup de bêtises
oui
mais a fait qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est qu'est ce qui fait que même macron
il est obligé de
de commémorer c'est la grandeur
d'un système politique qui permet aux
politiques de d'être indéboulonnable
oui face à un peu oui un peu on peut
dire ça moi je suis pas un fan de
napoléon et une phrase de jacques baril
qui dit sauf pour l'honneur sauf pour la
gloire il eût mieux valu que n'eut pas
existé mais en fait ce que je vais vous
dire là en
moi je j'essaie de vivre en imitant mon
père c'est le principe des mutations
mon grand-père migrants percement 14
dans l'ain et est mort à la tête de sa
compagnie
à la bataille du grand couronné le 8
septembre 1914 encore uniforme
maniable et bon je vis à travers lui et
je me dis là on a promises en quelque
chose avec vous en faites du quelqu'un
il pense à quoi ils pensent à roland
avec son corps et de bertrand c'est ça
oui
gillon
baudelaire et pense avions et le dit
victor hugo veut écrire comme
chateaubriand cercle en fait est par
exemple un jeune militaire aujourd'hui
pensent ou coloniales bertram le colonel
bertram l'a dit et pensé à turenne en
d'autres termes
le le le
un
français
quand il ya encore une école avec les
hussards noirs de la république mais moi
j'ai vécu encore dans une école qui
tenait debout
une comptes publics écoles privées mais
c'était la même chose s'était pas
c'était pas très différent
je je
le matin
quand je vois le soleil je pensais au
service quand
le soir
je gens nous regardent et à l'aise je
pense aux serments de 14 le
la nuit je pense à ce pauvre benjamin
fondane qui laisse un poème
extraordinaire c'est à vous que je parle
des antipodes je parle d'hommes avec le
peu de voix qui me reste de l'homme
c'est le le en fait c'est la kali de
scop c'est un grand manège c'est une
mise en image allégorique une nation et
et d'ailleurs depuis qu'on parle
ensemble toutes les références que que
que vous avez ce sont des c'est la
sédimentation d'une éducation et
donc
c'est une chronique un récit mais plus
que ça une légende tiens qu'un peuple
qui n'a plus de légende une vie plus et
qu'est ce que c'est une nation c'est
trois choses qu'on abandonne en ce
moment
c'est une histoire qu'on partage
avec un feeling à la grandeur parce que
sinon s'il n'y a pas la poésie
c'est
c'est la névrose
d'ailleurs la france ne s'est jamais
relevé de 40
c'est un pays névrosé alors que
l'angleterre elle vit encore sur le
discours de churchill
qui est dit plus tard vous souviendrez
j'étais là c'est parce que l'angleterre
n'a jamais été envahi
les pays de l'europe orientale eux ils
ont subi le joug soviétique mais ils ont
gardé leur identité on nous on est un
pays névrosée et un pays névrosé en fait
l'oubli et rédempteur
et donc il faut qu'on retrouve la fibre
la firme française donc une histoire
quand moi j'ai créé le puy du fou du puy
du fou c'est le légendaire français et
gens qui viennent
viennent chercher des racines que
parfois ils n'ont pas
puisqu'il ya deux manières d'être
français moi les plus français tous les
français que je connais dans mon
entourage c'est des français
qui ne sont pas français par l'origine
mais qui pratiquent la phrase de romain
gary
pas une goutte de sang français dans mes
veines mais la france n'en pas une
goutte de sang français mais c'est la
france qui coule dans mes veines et je
remarque qu'aujourd'hui par exemple ici
comme sonia mabrouk est d'origine
tunisienne qui a décrit un livre
admirable en fait elle est beaucoup plus
française elle souffre de la france est
libre à la france beaucoup plus que
beaucoup de français dit
d'origine et
peu importe d'où on vient ce qui compte
c'est où on va et
si on veut un jour à simuler
des
des petits français
de préfecture
dont on voudrait faire des français de
désir il faut leur donner envie de nous
ressemble et donc une histoire un art de
vivre qu'on ne célèbre plus un art de
vivre à la française et là je suis
désolé mais la france c'est plutôt des
clochers que des mines haye il n'y a pas
de tenues 7e siècle du prophète il faut
vivre à la française en français comme
ça
et enfin une langue qui n'est pas qu'un
véhicule la langue française c'est c'est
aussi une culture une manière de poser
son regard sur le monde voilà on sait
c'est toujours évolué dans des cycles
bien sûr bien sûr mais là jamais été
massacrés jusqu'à présent jours un chien
du bellay il a fait une mise à jour
de la clôture inclusive vous savez très
bien ce que ça veut dire déjà déjà 90%
des français ne connaissent pas la
langue française ne sera pas l'écrire
je peux vous dire que moi je travaille
dans le monde des écrivains les
écrivains qui écrivent en français n'a
pas beaucoup pour ça qu'il est justement
de partir
comment vous cuisinez jeu ce que vous
cuisinez je publie est-ce que vous
cuisinez
se mettre derrière les four doux à
l'oreille je fais
purée mousline sur le plat ça c'est pas
être français ça
on pourrait vous souvenir sur le plat et
quand il faut vraiment manger quand il
ya des invités ça alors ces incapables
et pourquoi
parce que
j'ai trop d'admiration
pour les non m ais je vous dis une chose
qui seront disait
timéo au new ce libellé brice hominem je
crains l'homme d'un seul livre et ça
c'est mon prof de français qu'il descend
première et je comprenais pas il
m'expliquait
spécial histoire dans un truc que tu
seras bien faire
la polyvalence c'est pour les gêner pic
de la mirandole bon donc moi je sais par
an de faire des spectacles je sais faire
des scénarii écrire bon
j'ai pas entendu vous savez faire dit je
sais faire des spectacles le pluriel de
scénario c'est quoi
je fais des scénarii êtes sûr de votre
coup là oui c'est arrivé
oui donc parmi les scénaristes ches les
scénarios de la sienne et celle du puy
du fou et de septembre
j'écris des livres bon mais
aimer mais comme je sais que c'est
difficile par me d'écrire un livre ou de
chats un scénario
je sais que j'en bave
quand je vois par exemple la grande la
belle cuisine française
par marc veyrat je connais bien que d'un
ami je
me fais goûter un truc si je comprends
pas voilà on ne peut pas transposer une
poésie
d'une strophe à l'autre sûr que chacun
mon réussi atteint peut pas être dans la
vie c'est déjà un exploit
mais comprend de la poésie du voisin la
goutte et oui voilà dans le meilleur des
cas donc tout est humble
le je suis pas musicien je joue de
l'harmonica c'est tout j'admire les
musiciens en fait
il suffit d'être un peu pointu dans un
art dans une compétence
poète pour se pâmer d'admiration sur les
autres
si vous n'avez pas d'art particulier
d'infection et d'affinités vont regarder
le monde d'un oeil différent
pourquoi vous avez soutenu jacques
chirac sur les essais nucléaires
chirac pour les essais nucléaires
je me suis un peu de ça mais
vous n'avez pas foutu les essais
nucléaires n'ont jamais maintenant je
sais trop jeune mais c'était avant
chirac jacques chirac mais roa vont je
n'étais pas encore de la vie politique
qu'est ce que vous pensez des gays des
des gays à égal c'est quoi les gars les
homosexuels les bisexuels
et les transsexuels
alors c'est simple
le
est-ce que vous avez la perception catho
tradi
c'est des sodomites il faut les envoyer
en enfer
où il devrait pas se reproduire des
choses comme ça quelle est votre
perception de saveurs d'abord on va être
très concret
j'ai des amis
qui sont restés sexuelles d'autres
questions sexuelles
d'accord mais vous en pensez d'accord
mais moi ce que j'en pense c'est que
deux hommes s'embrassent dans la rue
vous voyez l'amour où vous voyez deux
hommes s'embrasser
il ya le principe
et les hommes le principe est l'humain
je pense qu'une société
doit veiller à sa reproduction
sinon elle meurt sinon elle se stérilise
donc
ériger l'homosexualité en principe
c'est une erreur politique
moi je suis pour la vie et la
reproduction de la vie
ça c'est une chose
ensuite il ya l'aspect humain
l'aspect humain c'est très différents
aspects humains on vient
l'idée de
la sociabilité
la sociabilité ces deux de ne pas porter
de jugement sur son voisin
porter un jugement sur l'oise ainsi
remonté au niveau des principes donc je
suis la différence entre les deux
en revanche pas quand il ya deux hommes
qui s'embrassent dans la rue ces
indigènes à cause des enfants et si ces
deux femmes appareils
pourquoi cause des enfants à cause des
enfants parce que
je pense que dans leur
évolution personnelle
et il vaut mieux qu'ils soient tournés
vers la reproduction de la vie
plutôt que vers des formes de vie qui
sont différentes mais qui doit pas être
érigée qui peuvent êtres exceptionnels
qui peuvent être bourse est universel
comment est ce que l'amour c'est
universel amand s'est uni d'intérêt
oui bien sûr et ça c'est pas un principe
de vie alors met d'accord mais
je parle des principes de la survie
d'une société
et les sociétés qui ont érigé par
exemple l'homosexualité en principe de
ce sont mortes quelle société bain homme
voilà l'empiré romain
car
la grèce
est et tant d'autres que je ne connais
pas mais ces exemples là je les connais
bien donc on sait que vous pensez que la
grèce et rome se sont vautrés où les
mayas se sont vautrés parce que il y
avait des homosexuels moi je dis pas
voterait j'utilise pas de
ce genre de mots je le dis simplement ce
ont périclité non c'est simple non mais
c'est plus et plus c'est plus générale
que ça c'est plus
c'est plus grave que ça c'est en fait à
un moment donné un peu plus fatigués ils
se tournent plus vers la vie
sexuelle qui veut le voir des enfants
oui mais justement ils sont allés vers
le film est tourné vers l île mais je
vous prends l'utilisent à ce moment là
des broyats qui sont pas des ddd moyens
tout à fait naturel si on n'utilise pas
des six ont utilisé que des bouillons de
turin je suis absolument ce vote un
cancer de l'oeil ou way ici il vous dit
il aurait été résolu comme aux non
converties nages où vous aurez appelé
philippe le bord du nom les moyens
techniques
sont importants lorsqu'ils sont au
service
d'un bien supérieur en l'occurrence la
santé la gpa par exemple vous savez que
j'ai pas elle existe déjà et la gpa
ou tri ouais c'est la marchandisation du
corps j'avais été très choqué par
un grand patron attendez attendez on n'a
pas épuisé le sujet homosexuels on
passera la gpa juste après ouais
des gens qui s'aiment on est en france
le français sait reconnaître
l'amour dans les yeux le geste tendre et
alors
ça vous pose pas de problème dans sa
pose pas de problème à quoi ils sont
soit pas érigée en principe de société
c'est tout est-ce que vous répétez dix
fois la même chose alors passons là j'ai
pu mais voilà et
parce que si c'est érigée en principe de
société
le i ce pas ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui en occident l'occident est
en train de mourir pourquoi ils meurent
parce que il n'a plus le goût de la vie
de la survie
le goût de la survie elle est tellement
important que vous avez beaucoup
d'homosexuels qui vivent en couple qui
va avoir un enfant c'est l'idée de se
prolonger est ce que je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure sur la grèce et rome
c'est qu'à un moment donné
ils abandonnent leur dieu parce qu'il
n'ya plus d'avenir c'est très
intéressant à observer c'est toujours
pareil et il abandonne la vie ils n'ont
plus envie de vivre en fait ils ont plus
envie de survivre
eh ben c'est ce qui nous arrive en fait
c'est ce qui arrive en ce moment à
l'occident et à la france c'est qu'en
fait
on fait de moins en moins un enfant
on est de moins en moins tourner vers la
vie
parce que la ligne de flottaison de
l'espoir c'est l'enfant on a de moins en
moins envie de se prolonger parce qu'on
se dit que sera demain c'est comme ça
que les civilisations meurent en fait
alors rage et perd alors la cpa en fait
nous fait entrer dans le commerce
inéluctablement
et
au début on prête son corps puis très
rapidement se développent une filière
c'est déjà le cas l'air et donc à ce
moment là vous aurez une division du
monde trans humaniste
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya des gens très
différents du point de vue philosophique
qui seraient requis ce qui se rejoignent
sur ce que je vais vous dire maintenant
vous aurez des des peuples pauvres
qui cherchons les moyens de survivre les
français
je suis français la france étant un pays
du tiers monde avec une grande équipe de
football c'est toutes les
caractéristiques mais
je pensais aux alliances je pensais aux
africains de settat et par exemple avec
le transhumanisme vous pourrez
y aura déjà il ya les trafics d'organes
mais donc il ya des gens pauvres qui qui
donna rhin et ça se sait pas mais j'ai
horrible qu'on en soit là et en fait ben
la mère qui porte l'enfant
allait forcément tenter si elle est très
pauvre pour faire vivre sa famille valet
et donc faut pas qu'on se mettre dans
cette situation là en termes de
civilisation
la marchandisation du corps c'est la fin
d'une civilisation
si je vous dis décroissance ça vous fait
penser à quoi
ça me fait penser aux khmers verts
pourquoi parce que les khmers verts ils
veulent trois choses ils veulent la
décroissance
ils veulent
décarbonée mais en fait ils vont car
donner un peu plus pour les raisons que
je disais tout à l'heure et ils veulent
transformer le pays en un camp de
rééducation
pour ça que j'appelle le merzer commis
les khmers rouges alors les écrans sens
en fait
c'est
une mauvaise vision de la croissance
d'accord y'a pas de problème
donc là au nom de la décroche on dit en
fait on dit
il faut faire attention à ce que
la croissance
ne soit pas synonyme de pollution
et du coup on va la décroissance à la
décroissance par exemple quand
on dit il faut plus d'avion parce que
l'avion ça peut lui faut plus de
voitures en ville parce que ça pollue
ce que dit klaus schwab dans son livre
la réinitialisation du monde est dit a
bien sûr c'est agréable de faire du vélo
mais en fait il vaut mieux rester chez
soi devant whatsapp et faire du vélo
d'appartement
là en fait on voudrait nous vendre le
virus climatique derrière le co2
derrière le virus coronavirus
pour nous faire entrer dans un tunnel où
on resterait chez soi parce que dès
qu'on sorte que ce soit on peut lui
et cette idée que on reste chez soi à
numériser pour décarbonée
c'est une idée mortifère parce que la
décroissance
augmentera les problèmes elle ne les
résoudra pas
exemple
chirac a voulu bien faire et il a mis la
constitution le principe de précaution
très bien mc on veut aller plus loin
enfin il voulait aller plus loin votre
vie
décidemment va falloir qu'on parle de
mon ami parce que à chaque fois on me
dit vous
demandez lui et mes souhaits je vais
répondre à pas parce que la provoquer
vous avez perchée bat karé ment
non ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
le
j'ai perdu le fil des braques aux doigts
de votre ami dick oui c'est ça l'écocide
là le fameux écocide vous faire
attention parce que
aujourd'hui
autour de moi je vois des entrepreneurs
qui ont des idées d'entreprises mais ils
les mettront pas en appeler ils ont peur
d'être accusée d' écocide soit si on si
on crée une suspicion généralisée
surtout tous les entrepreneurs
au nom d'une pureté
de la planète et de la décroissance
verte
il se passera plus rien or là il ya une
urgence
changement une de vos intuitions
il faut amener de l'industrie chez nous
il faut relocaliser je dis pas que ce
sera facile
mais c'est absolument indispensable
en tout cas relocaliser tous les biens
essentiels
tout les intérêts vitaux
si on se soumet aux principes de la
décroissance bas on va tous alors la
décroissance vous neutre est qu'elle va
très bien que le numérique parce que
l'idée du numérique et de
l'automatisation et l'intelligence
artificielle
ces deux
on a plus besoin du travail
et on n'a plus besoin de l'entreprise
donc on est au télétravail on est tenté
d enseignement le présentiel des merdes
en ciel sita et on change de société
c'est à dire que en fait ce qu en train
de se passer là on passe d'une société
de liberté une société de surveillance
et on passe d'une société de voisinage à
une société distancié dans cette société
distancié c'est le et qui gagne
c'est à dire en fait la création
abstraite il ya plus de relations
humaines il ya plus de classe moyenne et
à leur revenu universel aa pour tenir
les gens tranquilles chez eux
financée sur l'argent magique mais ça ce
jeu c'est une c'est une contre société
alors là mais macron ans juste avant la
nive accroc ouais quels sont pour vous
les principes de quels sont pour vous
les fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
société
les principes fondamentaux
d'habilité d'une société de sudan de
consommation énergétique des choses
comme ça ça vous parle
là la consommation énergétique a aimé ça
ça me parle le plus que ça oui
je pense que
le
pour que la société
vivent en paix dans l'harmonie
il faut deux conditions
que tout soit fait pour le temps long le
temps long donc éviter toutes les formes
de gaspillage
et tout ce qui ressemble consommateur
compulsif qui vit dans l'instant
et deuxièmement faut assurer la
stabilité de la société c'est à dire
qu'on ait encore envie d'être ensemble
et donc qu'on partage non seulement la
même civilisation mais
la même manière de vivre et que les
écarts entre les uns et les autres ne
soient pas trop grand
non seulement les écarts dans la manière
de vie mais aussi les écarts de salaires
par exemple
or la mondialisation à la favoriser un
système dans lequel vous allez 1% la
population mondiale qui gagne
je sais combien de fois plus que le
reste de l'humanité donc si vous avez
une société toutes les sociétés qui
connaissent un déséquilibre des
catégories sociales
une manière différente de vives par
rapport à la peine qu'on prend pour
vivre
toutes ces sociétés là ils ont périclité
la mondialisation nous impose un modèle
puissamment inégalitaire
il ya les profiteurs de la
mondialisation les élites globalisé
et elle est victime de la mondialisation
la mondialisation c'est un système dans
lequel ce sont les pauvres des pays
riches qu'il subventionne les riches des
pays pauvres
puisque ça consiste à les produire la
hausse est de moins cher l'on peut
exploiter des gens
pourquoi pas des petits enfants indiens
fabriquent nos pulls pour venir vendre
là où y'a encore du pouvoir d'achat
le côté sécessionnistes des élites
la sécession fiscale
comment on fait pour endiguer l'évasion
fiscale selon philippe de villiers
c'est intéressant parce que c'est le mot
que je cherchais à l'heure n'est de
trouver ces sessions en fait qu'on m'a
demandé la définition des élites
globalisé
et bien la réponse elles ont fait
sécession
et d'ailleurs les élites globalisé sont
tout à fait ravis de voir qu'il ya des
territoires en france qui font sécession
ça ne dérange pas on sait quels
territoires bas tous les territoires qui
sont plus
souvent ceux qui sont plus qui ne vit
plus qu'ils ne vivent plus qu'à la
française dans lesquels on ne peut plus
faire entrer les pompiers des médecins
et les policiers
ben je vous dirais un territoire
que par exemple salling grade
le crack
et les casseroles tous les soirs qui
manifestent que ils ont envie de revivre
voilà jeu chez nous
on paie on parle toujours malade oui
pendant que jean lanneaux mais on peut
aussi prendre des quartiers
qui sont par exemple les quartiers où
prospèrent l'indigénisme le
monde
on parle de la blanche cité
où
on considère qu'il ya en france
et dans l'histoire de france à racisme
systémique
avec cette culture qui vient de
l'université de leurs graines qui
s'implantent chez nous la cancel culture
quand j'entends assa traoré pop
j'ai peur parce que désigne la france
comme un pays raciste
et donc il ya des quartiers qui vivent
selon une loi qui n'est plus la nôtre
je joue je dirais je vous le concède
est ce qu'il ya des du racisme en france
alors il ya du racisme partout
le
racisme
est vieux comme l'humanité
mais
je crois pas qu'on puisse désigner un
peuple comme étant spécialement assists
et je suis outré
par la cancel culture vient l'idée de
traquer par la culture française
au nom de l'antiracisme est une forme de
racisme exemple est un groupe de travail
à l'opéra qu'a rendu son rapport
sur
pour que mon virage
décoloniser le répertoire
le mot est utilisé
sites ayant fait censurer le répertoire
comme la bayadère le lac des cygnes
parce que il ya trop de densité parce
qu'il ya des chaussons roses je blague
pas on en est là
qu on interdise les têtes de [__] dans
l'est dans les boulangeries non mais ça
ok et bien sûr mais c'est pas du tout la
même échelle c'est pas du tout le même
principe le le fait qu'on puisse parler
de racisme systémique à propos de
des français
le fait que
mais ça va même plus loin que ça et
essai il ya parfois une entreprise de
décolonisation chez nous
qui ressemble à une nouvelle
colonisation c'est-à-dire en nous
explique
que la france est une puissance
coloniale
chez elle
et qu'il faut le décoloniser la france
ah bon ça veut dire qu'en fait
la france est un pays occupé en quelque
sorte par nous la france est un pays
occupé par les français
c'est pas raisonnable voilà et ce
racisme systémique d'inde qui fait dire
à l'unef
interdit aux blancs mais c'est quoi ça
rendit compte que on a eu la lutte des
classes
et maintenant on aurait la lutte des
races
et c'est ce qui pendant des années des
décennies nous ont fait la leçon avec
sos racisme qui luttait contre le
racisme
et qui impose aujourd'hui
cette guerre civile larvée entre en
fonction de la couleur de peau
sous les jeux vous dire quelque chose
qui est quelqu'un que le filigrane de
mon livre
le great reset de klaus schwab la grande
réinitialisation du monde
c'est la numérisation du fort intime
c'est à dire ils veulent nous voler
notre fort intime les géants du
numérique et leurs alliés attendez vous
dites détruire l'image comment il faut
détruire l'image que les gens se font de
lents pays c'est ça
oui mais c'est aussi
l'idée de nous contrôler et donc à une
double surveillance surveillance civique
surveillance marchande
j'arrive le
entre le grétry 7 et la cancel culture
il ya deux points communs c'est le
culture ne pensais pas que si c'est si
la micro-société parisianiste de saint
germain
qui utilise ça vous connaissez la france
comme et alors et quand j'étais j'étais
dans l'oeuf ou le fonds du cul de la
bretagne à cinq jours alors parler de là
quand c'est leur culture quand ça
commence toujours comme ça
ça commence toujours comme ça mais là
quand c'est à une culture pop le fait
que moi je puisse par exemple faire une
conférence à sciences po
je suis ancien élève de sciences po le
fait que ces
abats demandez leur mais je pourrais pas
passer aux tourniquets voilà tandis que
je termine et je vais vous répondre là
dessus parce que s'il ya de la gaze
inscrits pape devait faire une
conférence à bordeaux à l'université
elle a pas pu et aujourd'hui
à l'université dans les universités de
province d'où venait de me parler
la conseillère culture elle se répand
comme une traînée de poudre et donc là
quand cette culture c'est l'annulation
ou des plateformes c'est l'effacement
c'est la table rase le great reset en
réinitialisant on met sur 0
c'est la table rase ça c'est le premier
point commun mais il y en a un deuxième
c'est l'assignation à résidence avec le
gris de reset c'est l'assignation à
résidence numérique la société distancié
la société du contrôle et avec
la console culture c'est l'assignation à
résidence chromatique en fonction de la
couleur de peau en fonction de votre
couleur de peau c'est l'assignation à
résidence par la vindicte le contrôle la
vindicte cette société là quand un être
au contact de la cancel culture donc de
la vindicte l'assignation chromatique et
l'assignation numérique avec le gâteries
7 elle est invivable il faut vraiment la
refuser
question internet
est il favorable ali vigie non
parce que je suis écologique
et que quand j'ai vu le brigitte mâcon
qui était la marraine des pandas de
beauval
expliqué qu'il fallait sauver des pandas
j'ai trouvé ça formidable
la femme du chef de l'état qui se
déplacent pour sauver des pandas
et moi je ne veux pas faire un sort
particulier aux petits hommes
je suis pour sauver l'espèce humaine je
suis désespéré de voir chez moi qu'il ya
plus de maisons
j'ai compris mes questions oui c'était
quoi la question
les vg ce qui veut dire
l'avortement
est donc
ce qu'on accepte pour le petit homme au
cas là il pas compris ma réponse j'avais
complété
on n'accepterait pas pour les animaux
dans beaucoup de cas
voilà et donc euh moi je suis pour la
vie
je pense que il faut protéger la vie
et
voyez par exemple là on a prolongé le
délai de l'avortement jusqu'à neuf
semaines c'est en fait neuf semaines
c'est l'infanticide neuf mois par an
pendant le coït en cas de détresse
sociale je précise mais bon c'est quoi
une détresse sociale et la 9 mois et
donc je pense que c'est un engrenage
s'ils ont une veille quand elle a fait
sa loi et la dilatation de la vie est
sacrée et dans certains cas
exceptionnels de détresse état et puis
tout s'est renversée maintenant est un
pays qui compte 200 1000 avortements par
an c'est un pays qui ne nous regardent
plus l'avenir puisque
c'est un pays qui va disparaître et
penser de la politique de l'enfant
unique en chine
j'ai
très choquée que la puissance publique
puisse intervenir dans la vie des
couples et en l'occurrence dans la vie
d'une famille qui peut être un deuxième
enfant
j'espère que ça n'arrivera pas en france
qu'est ce qui se passe quand il ya trop
de criquets dans un champ à
votre comparaison
vous appartient quand l'humanité devient
nuisible pour ce même sur les reproduire
auto école donc je pose la question
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont cherché
à résoudre le problème j'étais pas très
clair non plus voilà et donc le
moi je suis pas prenez la question ce
sont sont rentrés de même votre question
je vais la traduire comme vous me direz
si j'ai compris ce que vous avez dit si
je me suis bien d'exprimer oui ou non
vous êtes poney toujours très bien non
c'est le problème d'une planète
où il ya trop d'hommes par rapport aux
ressources
voilà c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai
problème d'éducation des peuples c'est
mais juste je pense pas que la solution
soit de tuer les gens et
il faut trouver des solutions qui
concilie de l'éducation
et la liberté la liberté des familles la
liberté des enfants la liberté des
parents la liberté des peuples
parce que par exemple
enfin
manière plus générale
il faut être
tournés vers la vie
tourné vers la vie ça veut dire plutôt
que de supprimer des gens il vaut mieux
augmenter les richesses trouver des
richesses
faire en sorte qu'on puisse vivre qu'on
puisse survivre
il ya deux choses qui me font très peur
par rapport à votre question
la première c'est le génie sme
c'est à l'idée de sélectionner
ceux qui vont vivre ça a déjà été
pratiqué je mets en chine s'était
particulier par les nazis et
le
on voit bien qu'il ya cette tentation
l'enfant parfait tu sais et deuxièmement
le transhumanisme
quelqu'un que vous je sais pas si vous
êtes sensible à ça c'est terrible ce qui
se prépare cirque en fait c'est une
secte oui mais mais la secte elle a le
pouvoir c'est vega fin c'est à dire que
vous avez le titre de time en 2019 qui
dit
google va supprimer la mort
est en dessous et un sous titre qui dit
ce serait une plaisanterie ce n'était
pas google et l'article explique que
google a mis dans sa vitrine un nouvel
article
d'articles comme un épicier mais une
nouvelle marchandise ces nouvelles artix
et
l'immortalité
donc ces gens
qui ont gagné beaucoup d'argent
tellement d'argent qu'ils en ont plus
besoin
on voit des satellites pour pérenniser
leur pouvoir
pour capter notre sphère intime pour
nous géolocalisé
pour nous pour faire de nous des
marchandises puisque le produit c'est
nous
mais ça va plus loin maintenant
ils veulent faire un ogre augmenté
je précise par rapport à votre question
tout à l'heure de l'oeil
quand quand
on peut
réparer l'homme
grâce aux progrès techniques faut pas
hésiter par exemple le bras bionique
c'est à
tout ce qui va dans le sens de la
réparation de l'homme
l'homme augmenté c'est différent on
fabrique un homme différent surpasse la
création de diou
alors c'est exactement ça s'écoute
des airs it is vous serez comme des
lieux et ses tentatives de divinisation
de l'homme
va tuer l'homme
et l'homme masqué une phrase terrible
qui se veut drôle si tu vois tu peux pas
dominer la machine devient une machine
et pour me faire bien comprendre ce
qu'envisage dégâts femmes qui
travaillent sur cette question notamment
google c'est de faire un homme machine
un homme robot qui parlant d' pourrait
déposer ses souvenirs
certes c'est la machine qu'il remplace
et la machine plus puissante que cerveau
humain se substitue au cerveau humain
et c'est cette humanité
et plaisante sur le papier et sera
invivable d'autant plus invivable qu'il
ya des gens que pourront pas se payer la
machine mais ça va créer des inégalités
intellectuelle il ya déjà des qualités
intellectuelles on voit le caution des
quotients intellectuels des français
plongé
mais vous avez fait une belle diversion
revenons à la surpopulation ali vg à
tout ça qu'est ce qui se passe quand il
ya trop de criquets dans le bocal
ma grand mère disait quand il n'ya plus
de foin dans les râteliers je voulais
terminer ma phrase ouais
des chevaux se bat oui
bel sont
les guerres mondiales entité provoqué
à mon avis par les états unis
pour des raisons qui tenait des logiques
de puissance
je suis pas assez spécialiste pour
m'avancer plus avant sur ce terrain
mais je vois bien je voyais pas ce que
vous vouliez dire là je le vois très
bien effectivement
struggle for life
c'est à dire que il ya plusieurs
manières de résoudre des problèmes de la
surpopulation est à la une car a dit
karl c'est la guerre les épidémies
vous les épidémies alors là vous allez
sur un terrain
je veux bien vous accompagner je veux
bien vous suivre
[Rires]
on n'apprend pas un vieux macaques à
faire la grimace à vous êtes plutôt
juste comme mac
va prendre ça comme un compliment
c'est un compliment
je me suis dit pour qu'ils aient un tel
succès il doit y avoir à sortir est
quelque part c'est pas la technique même
si technique est parfaite
mais je suis ravi cette conversation
parce que
ça me permet de dire beaucoup de choses
que souvent je n'ai jamais dit
et en essayant d'être le plus précis
possible et le plus le plus franc il est
toute l'année scolaire le tout dans le
respect alors là vous allez poser la
fameuse question alors à saveur là vous
êtes aux portes du complotisme
que vous êtes en train de dire de
sous-entendre à mais finalement il ya
des gens qui auraient intérêt
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
bon qu'est ce que vous avez voulu dire
j'ai écouté vous j'ai écouté vous vous
interview et quand l'on peut être que
j'ai mal compris
vous décriviez le le rassemblement de
l'exercice de goede coronavirus peu
d'anticipation d'une crise d'une
pandémie mondiale comme il y en a ils
devaient taux courants ça arrange on va
se faire du blé ça va réduire la
population est peut-être une chose comme
ça ouais je vous tend une perche
c'était pas ça ce que vous souhaitiez
expliquer aux gens lui non non vous avez
1 1
un arrière-goût
dont la teneur non mais je vais être
très précis
les complotistes sont des gens qui mal
informés
tombe dans le fantasme pour s'expliquer
une situation exactement
donc ils cherchent des clés qu'ils n'ont
pas
ils ont des excuses je vais vous dire
pourquoi
et du coup
il pense par exemple que le virus a été
inventé
moi je ne le crois pas
j'ai dit ils ont des excuses est ce que
en fait
et à ceux qui
fantasment et à ceux qui mentent
et quand un complotiste voit un menteur
un peu orwell serait là aujourd'hui il
formera un gouvernement il nommerait
docteur verron ministre de la vérité
par dérision
quand par exemple
on nous a dit les marches de cf tarja
et qu'ensuite on nous a dit il faut tous
porter le masque forcément ça engendre
de complotisme quand on nous a dit
selon l'institut pasteur il y aura cinq
cent mille morts
donc il faut qu'on finit en masse
forcément ils sont mis quand même
comment on a eu 100 milles oui mais
c'est pas 500 mille parce qu'on m'a
confirmé souhait c'est pas la peine de
mentir bon quand
on va prendre un autre exemple que plus
spectaculaire et plus récents
il ya un an
les gens qui disaient y compris les
scientifiques c'est peut-être pas le
pangolin qui est à l'origine de
l'épidémie
et a peut-être eu un accident de
laboratoire
il était traité de conspirationnistes
il ya deux jours traitez pas requis par
les pouvoirs en place et tous ceux qui
les accompagnent et qui en profite et
qui profitent de la situation
aujourd'hui un article dans le monde une
page anarchie dans le figaro une page
qui explique
bahia une trentaine de scientifiques qui
ont écris à l'om s'en disent enchantés
oui
bon ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
ya peut-être eu un accident de
laboratoire c'est tout mais moi je mange
en reste tout fait je dis simplement que
je dis simplement que
les géants du numérique et observait
tout ça le monde pathogens état il se
préparait ce monde pathogènes
et l'exercice de simulation danger par
l'état leur en fait c'était pour dire
bon se prépare parce que tu as ton il va
y avoir à coville ils sont préparés oui
d'accord mais sinon ça veut dire solide
et un coq oui c'est cool et ça va me
dire ça veut dire que
il aurait pu dire
il faut fermer les frontières tout de
suite puisqu'il va arriver il ce qu'ils
l'ont dit mais on savait rien il s'est
préparé c'est tout non vous vous les
connaissez ces colloques ça permet de
faire du recrutement ça change dit qu'un
environnement c'est un exercice
ce cas et c'est un exercice ils ont un
scénario une mise en scène et à aucun
moment il y en a un cas ni dans ce cas
là il faut peut-être fermer le coso
avant avant qu'il ne soit trop tard mais
non pourquoi si on ferme les cloisons
c'est pas bon pour le numérique
qu'est ce que la big tech il faut bien
comprendre qu'on est il faut que les
gens qui nous écoutent et nous entende
entendre ça c'est la nouvelle
suzeraineté nous sommes les serres de la
glèbe numérique appelée à être implanté
puce et le puçage d'universel voilà et
donc il avance il avance il avance
regardez le beurre qu'ils ont fait
qui sont les victimes du coc vide bercy
principale victime du coup vite merci
les taxes alors merci
bruno le maire
bruno le maire il a pendant le coït
trois emplois du temps
et la 3me tokyo
le matin et les cris il fait des
vocalises pour exprimer ses états d'âme
et parle de pascal c'est un
jeu soit effet lci les plateaux tv
fait aller le trouver le temps de faire
un livre
après deuxième mi temps il fait fermer
tous les commerces qui sont en
infraction
les petits commerces commerce de
proximité fait fait pas fermé amazon
et puis à la fin de la journée ils
distribuent les dragées dépêchés eux
c'est le dispensateur des contributions
les ports pour que chacun sa perfusion
perfusion son shoot mais très bonne
question je vous laisse le choix du
terme
parce que
quand on va ôter la perfusion la
joute où son shoot
je sais pas je suis pas assez
compétent médicalement mais quand on ose
tout
la privation
oddo table non je suis bien joué un vase
déjà figure jamais jamais
si vous mais 68 à
j'étais joueur de foot et j'avais pas
envie de compromettre ma carrière parce
que je pensais qu'un jour je serai
arrière central du fc nantes et mon père
m'a dit un jour nantes et pas assez bon
pour ça nous a libérés mais si vous
voulez parler de la droite qu'on peut en
parler après demain il faudra parler du
cannabis c'est à moi je sais je sais
revenons à le dr voilà
qui refusent ou l'appétit des
entreprises est alors en fait là il va y
avoir je vous prédis de manière un peu
métaphorique de deux files d'attentes je
commençais aujourd'hui ça va se voir
dans quelques jours ou quelques semaines
et quelques mois la première files
d'attentes
sellafield attentes de la joie l'écrit
comme ils disent la libération
c'est à files d'attentes devant les
bistrots demain les restaurants à
l'extérieur d'abord puis à l'intérieur
ensuite les cinémas etc on va revivre
c'est une belle files d'attentes mais il
ya une autre files d'attentes qu'on voit
pas encore se former sellafield attentes
de tous les morts vivants
devant le greffe du tribunal du commerce
et 7 files d'attentes pour bien
connaître les entreprises devant
département je peux vous dire que ça va
être impressionnant
parce que
on a fait un choix
confinement de masse très bien pendant
un an
on n'a pas lésiné
moi je pense que la grandeur de la
politique c'est c'est le spectre de la
vie de toutes les vies la vie
prophylactique mais aussi la vie
créative la vie économique la vie
sociale la culture à la vie spirituelle
ça toute la ville toutes les dix très
bien le philosophe comte sponville
et là en fait
on a permis
au numérique de développer
télétravail tel est l'enseignement etc
en revanche
tous les petits métiers
qu'avait déjà besoin d'argent qu'avait
déjà peu d'argent
ils sont au tapis vous allez voir qu'il
ya un bistrot sur doha restant sur deux
qui va pas sortir et pourquoi parce que
quand vous allez au thé le shoot
qu'on va leur dire un temps fort en
bourse et
et vous savez pourquoi mâcon se
présentera pas
pour revenir à notre question de tout à
l'heure j'ai trouvé de bien vous voulez
pas payer comment la tournée de bière
que vous voulez pas payer
[Rires]
parce qu'en fait il a joué avec le feu
et la dé l'argent magique et donc le
gars qui à la base a du mal à assurer
ses fins de mois
il dit à macron alors
votre vos stratégies votre théorie du
ruissellement ça marche pas et macron
dit mais je peux pas inventer l'argent
que j'ai pas
après fillon qui avait dit on est en
faillite donc il est clair il y aura un
nom est plus il ya plus d'argent dans
les caisses
alors après ce qu il n'y a plus d'argent
dans les caisses on vend les bijoux de
famille oui pour ça qu'on a vendu alstom
voilà qui aliment bien sûr et
le pirée le port du pirée et c'est à
l'aéroport de toulouse et c'est ce que
le début alors tout à coup tout à coup
le corps n'a virus arrive et à l'argent
magique mettez vous à la place d'un
ouvrier
oda chômeurs 1 passe quand ils vont nous
refaire le coup là ça il ya plus
d'argent magique là vous allez voir bon
et donc et ça va tabassé un peu puis
tout de suite ça va recouvrer un agent
logic alors alors attendez mais ça va
d'abord quand même ça ça va déménager ça
va ramener dans la cheminée parce que
les gens qui
entendait le discours
la rigueur la rigueur la rigueur il faut
gérer les critères de maastricht et
d'ailleurs les commissaires de landi et
la cour des comptes et monsieur
moscovici
ancien ministre du budget socialiste
philippe seguin
philippe seguin philippe séguin oui bon
ça c'est une autre période il est mort
oui mais il disait ça il disait même
raison la crise financière 2008
oui on était déjà dans la merde oui
exactement mais donc et avait le se
disent qu en disant attention et c'est à
tout à coup
l'argent coule à flots et alors
et puis maintenant il va puis avoir
d'argent vous allez voir bon pourquoi
pas ce qu'ils font payer des dettes
parce que ma grand-mère me disait
toujours tu sais une date ici potocki
l'appel sera trop petit fils qui la
paiera et là en fait c'est terrible ce
qui se passe il nous explique on a
cantonné en main c'est pourquoi je
comprends rien à ce qu'ils prévoient moi
c'est basique depuis les grecs et les
romains et même chez les amérindiens
quant à une date tu la payes parce que
c'est pas toi qui la paye à une
injustice car il ya un baiser dans le
circuit
et donc il va falloir payer à l'ailette
de l'inflation ben je sais pas
je sais pas comment on va faire mais ça
va pas suffire inflation parce que de
toute façon
alors ya quelque chose de malsain dans
la mondialisation heureuse ce qui est
malsain
là je vais dire je vais parler que
comme un artisan
dans mon enfance
quand secte avant l'argent que tu as
poids
mais
c'est pas de l'argent vrai
et ça prépare un malheur en d'autres
termes quand vous déconnecter la finance
de l'économie réelle serge termine
toujours mal
avant de passer à votre ali macron
question internet combien vous gagnez
combien gagne t il et que pense-t-il des
héritages
alors moi j'ai une retraite
qui est de l'ordre de 5000 euros
oui
wind est
la retraite de parlementaire
points
et j'ai mes droits d'auteur
sur mes livres mais encore une fois pas
de droits d'auteur sur le pidou
et
c'est pas si c'est pas le droit d'auteur
en france en sont complices ils sont à
50 % pris par l'état donc voilà
c'est donc bien donc je je bush
l'heureux
s'est pas
demandé avant 10 heures qu'est-ce qui
fait les comptes chez vous c'est votre
expert-comptable lorsque ma femme
ouais il partage des rôles voulut pas
appeler votre femme ben vous pouvez
l'appeler mais
et six étages et il y avait une autre
question c'était les héritages qui
pense-t-il des héritages
ben
je suis pour les héritages parce que
c'est la seule manière
de transmettre un bien à ses enfants
et
les héritages ça vous permet quand vous
êtes vivant de travailler pour l'avenir
pas que pour vous
et donc c'est une motivation
supplémentaire
c'est les dettes se prolonger la
taxation sur les héritages vous en
pensez quoi abbas est normal que l impôt
sur les héritages
mais
la limite de cet impôt ce qu'il ne faut
pas qu'il soit court fils catoire dire
que si vous n'avez pas un peu pendant 20
ans
accumulé pour pouvoir acheter une maison
et que cette maison vous êtes confisqué
puisque moment de l'héritage les enfants
pas de quoi payer l'impôt
c'est plus du jeu voilà et à la faune en
france on est la limite de sa
question l'internet quel est le futur de
la france dans l'union européenne
je pense que
il faut faire le brix élite
c'est à dire virer les commissaires et
faire la grande europe confédérale
faire un peu ce que font les allemands
c'est à dire nous
on est européen puisque c'est notre
civilisation est européenne toute terre
quêter
romanisée christianisé soumise à
l'esprit la discipline des grecs c'est
la définition de paul valéry donc les
pressions de sortir de l'europe question
de sortir bruxelles de l'europe
bruxelles les commissaires qui nous
gouvernent voilà donc reprendre notre
souveraineté et pour le reste faire avec
les uns et les autres une configuration
une configuration où opèrent ensemble
sur des choses qu'on peut pas faire tout
seul par exemple la lutte contre le
terrorisme
par exemple l'espace par exemple les
grands projets de la recherche médicale
des choses que ça y est c'est à le
principe de subsidiarité
ce que je ne peux pas faire seul je le
confie à
une structure qui est plus qu est plus
large que moi et qui a plus de potentiel
que moi c'est le principe de la
subsidiarité
aujourd'hui on fait exactement l inverse
et donc je crois que l'europe de
maastricht
elle est morte elle est morte parce que
l'angleterre a donné le ton ça marchait
leur truc ça marchait le mondial
le l'europe pénitentiaire
tant que les gens croyaient qu'on
pouvait pas s'en aller
je me suis a très très bien mother
de tous les grands européiste qui disait
comme barnier devant bon encore il n'ya
pas longtemps mais nos médecins possible
on peut pas quitter l'europe c'est pas
dans les statuts ben voilà et puis tout
à coup la paix qui est dit merde bon là
ce qui se passe regardez l'europe
les critères de maastricht fini les
vaccins s'est faite
sous l'identité européenne solidarité
européenne on n'en parle pas ou ce
ballet frontières
schengen aux soldats schengen terminée
c'est la pagaille
on nous disait sous les traits
l'importance que je vais vous dire
moi jusqu'à il m'expliquait
l'europe ce sera une grande france on
sera puissant les etats-unis n'ont qu'à
bien se tenir on va faire les états unis
d'europe
en fait on n'a pas du tout fait ça on a
fait une annexe du marché américain
et
l'industrie européenne la puissance
économique européenne
on sait ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
le groupe devise grade c'est à dire la
tchéquie la croatie la la slovaquie
plutôt la pologne et la hongrie ils sont
mal vus par les commissaires de
bruxelles à mon avis sont sur le départ
pour des raisons de civilisation
serre que eux ils disent venu on veut
pâtissent la mise et vous allez this
tamisée vous cherchez vous faites tout
pour ça
ensuite et lé pays du nord frugaux les
cigales au sud
souhait
pourrait vous êtes en train de me faire
le pigs portugal irlande grèce espagne
pardon vous n'êtes pas en train de me
dire les pays lépi
sigal
portugal grèce espagne vous n'êtes pas
en train de faire que le système a du
moins là pas du tout d'accord alors non
le nom moi je le dis chaque pays fait
comme il peut comme il veut
c'est un jour j'ai rencontré mme
margaret thatcher et m'a dit une chose
juste elle m'a dit en français ou en
anglais
ben je crois bien qu'il a dit en
français elle a dit on s'est débarrassé
des commissaires à l'aise c'est papa à
voir les commissaires à l'ouest
je n'étais pas du tout d'accord avec sa
politique
mais là les raisons et
elle m'avait dit aussi un jour à
proposer malouines un peuple
perd sa puissance créatrice quand tu
perds ça certes et avons appris après
avoir pris à l'exo 7 abbas était
c'était avant
et
c'est bien l'histoire et
moi je suis convaincu
la lumière devant l'expérience
personnelle
alors vous me direz c'est un petit
exemple demander ça mais quand je suis
arrivé à
la tête du département des vendéens
baisser la tête alors que réussie c'est
bien de ça mais simplement on dire non
faut pas que ceux qui regardent leur
histoire c'est ils sont du mauvais côté
de l'histoire c'est à et il y avait une
espèce de honte
quand un peuple
travail et nourrit sa honte il peut pas
réussir économiquement et donc en fait
il faut que le peuple français retrouve
sa fierté et c'est aux hommes politiques
à faire l'effort pour que des écoles
on leur transmettent
les valeurs et le goût de la valeur
ajoutée ça c'est du wishful thinking
c'est des incantations là bas notre
classe notre classe notre caste
politique à banyas
notre classe politique cécile
kaki qui tient grâce à vos yeux dans
notre caste politique
notre personne parce que ils sont tous
les héritiers et théologique de ceux qui
ont abandonné les murs porteurs
personne donc les murs porteurs c'est
l'autorité la sécurité la liberté
l'identité souveraineté alors qui est
donc
le
les générations politiques qui sont
partagé le pouvoir
ont abandonné la france
j'ai vécu c'est à brno 1992
maastricht et mais ça avait commencé
avant ça avait commencé avant
pour moi le tournant c'est
giscard
quand il a dit qu'il voulait moderniser
la france fait il voulait américanisé la
france qu'ils appellent la décrispation
est en fait
au nom de la modernité
on a on a liquidé le pays
qui tient qui qui pourrait trouver grâce
à vos yeux dans notre caste d'hommes et
de femmes politiques alors moi je crois
que dans la caste reprendre rythme dans
la caste
il ya des gens de la caste
donc
qui ont subi
les déformations de la caste et qui
accompagnent les intérêts de la caste
regardé par un peu comment le le parti l
air est en train de s'effondrer de
disparaître de élire les le party les
républicains un bon marché différentes
façons en marché iclothing que depuis le
début et que c'est
mais tout ça c'est pareil c'est façon
ils veulent le multiculturalisme
l'europe et c'est le mondialisme au cul
sont d'accord fondamentalement
donc tous ceux qui ont participé
participe de cette idéologie
en fait mondialistes serre qui considère
que la france n'a plus sa raison d'être
et qui s'en foutent en plus
parce que
ils sont dans le service de l'eau de
leurs ambitions regardez l'histoire de
plus de lier de ça ça ça pulse à pul ça
pue pouvoir quoi
peut-être qu'en fait
un jour il ya olivier guichard qui m'a
dit la politique elle a basculé quand le
pouvoir
est devenue une consommation
ou une addiction
voilà et non plus un service
en fait il n'y a pas de liste il n'y a
pas d'autre activité que
la légitimité pour services rendus
le
est donc en fait il ya un prix pour les
trouver il faut trouver quelqu'un
d'extérieur il faut trouver quelqu'un
d'extérieur halak est quelqu'un
d'extérieur à la caste faire quelqu'un
qui n'est qu'il n'est pas
de
de la jante
quelqu'un qui n'est pas du phalanstère
quelqu'un qui n'est pas de la société de
connivences
cette association se protège et se
reproduit question internet est-ce que
nantes doit devenir la capitale de la
bretagne est ce que les corses sont
sécessionniste
est-ce que quoi est-ce que nantes à
nantes pardon doit devenir la capitale
de la bretagne
et est ce que les corses sont
sécessionniste alors je réponde aux
questions
premièrement
je pense que
l'idée que nantes soit en bretagne est
défendable
peut-être j'étais le nantais je
souhaiterais que nantes soit rattachée à
la bretagne
après c'est la sphère des bretons
est ce que ces noms tous que c'est
rennes je ne sais pas je connais bien la
bretagne parce que j'allais passer mes
vacances quand j'étais petit à saint
malo à roter neuf et donc j'ai une
passion pour la bretagne diffic comment
c'est magnifique il y bretons sont en
dessous du bon ouais adorable voilà et
donc alors nous les vendéens on est les
petits frères des bretons ce que c'est
le massif armoricain et en fait on a la
même mère
et la même ruse est ce qui vient du
granit du silex
donc nantes
voilà il ya une région des pays de la
loire qui veut rien dire comme beaucoup
de régions dire
voilà donc notre page peut pas répondre
à ça
mais je comprends que
enfin la région depuis la loi c'est un
no man's land ne se se dit breton ce
breton c'est moi je trouve ça
passionnant qui est des passionnés et
encore ça en france des gens qui sont
attachés et qui dit non non moi je suis
creusois jeu corrézien bon presque plus
à peu de terre oui
hélas les corses
alors les causes
et les romains des corses je sais pas
deux têtes mais ça doit être vrai je
pensais que vous l'aviez
c'est un corps s'ils se laissent mourir
plutôt que d'obéir ouais
alors moi le vendéen j'aime bien les
corses
parce que qu'ils n'aiment pas les corses
d'ailleurs non mais quand on est un peu
rebelle
indépendant d'esprit on se sent un peu
corse
et
si on veut que la que la corse
comprennent
la métropole alors l'ensemble auquel la
cancer attaché depuis depuis avant la
naissance de napoléon si ces 163 joie il
faut tout leur donner des libertés que
qu'ils ont perdu
et moi j'ai de la sympathie pour ce
faire hurler des gens mais pour les pour
les économistes
les nationalistes corses même s'il n'ya
pas de peuple corse puisque sans ce les
indépendantistes avec ou sans cagoule
non aux autonomistes et indépendantistes
je pense pas que ce soit le dessin de la
corse de quitter la france
mais je vais là encore c'est pas très
longtemps chez des amis à vivario
et j'étais vraiment dans ce long c'est
lui par ce pays que je ne connaissais
pas mais
la population
c'est encore une société
et donc au lieu de les regarder avec
méfiance on ferait mieux de les regarder
comme un modèle
alors évidemment il ya de la violence et
tout ça c'est les attentats mais ce
qu'il faut voir derrière tout ça s'il ya
une société
et il ya une fierté est en fait ton cul
ras dans l'aude en eau dans nos
provinces dans le camp qu'on appelle nos
régions
regardez ce qu'ils ont fait depuis 40
ans en fait
ils ont
noyé tout ce qui marchait pas lampe le
maire la commune
maintenant il ya les intercommunalités
les intercommunalités en fait c'est on
nous a la responsabilité
on sait plus qui fait quoi et puis de
responsable nulle part le maire quand on
lui dit mais c'est pas possible la
gouttière il ira sur la terre
communalité
bon les départements c'est une des
réussites de la révolution
créé en 1990
on est en train de les faire disparaître
pour les fondre dans les régions
toutes ces régions ne veulent
strictement rien dire et on fond l'état
dans l'europe donc double qu'en fait il
reste rien
de ce qui nous rattache
un sentiment d'appartenance
votre avis vaincre ou à ben justement un
jour je lui dis ça je lui ai dit il faut
rétablir les départements et les
communes il faut leur redonner
la compétence et la responsabilité il
m'a dit vous avez tout à fait raison il
en train de faire le contraire
alors mon hanina kron l'histoire est la
suivante
voulez jouer là raconte est vrai
je suis à la rotonde un soir
la brasserie
avec des amis et le patron lars entre
retourne me dis y'a le milieu économique
et 15 ans et qu'elle s'en bat avec son
épouse est ce que vous voudriez
descendre
je suis je sais pas qui sait de qui vous
parlez d emmanuel macron ne connaissez
pas
je dis non et puis il jours après ça
recommence je veux lui bon c'est pas la
peine
soyez polis quoi
je descends
et
ma vie ta
à m'asseoir avec eux
on parle
et là il me dit je rêve
de venir au puy du fou jeudi bahman sgt
il vient
et là il me dit je suis venu chercher
l'écho profond des tendresses française
formidable
il espérait avoir un longue échanger
avec moi en un longue échange avec moi
et je lui dis tout de suite je vous
préviens
inutile d'insister mais on est d'accord
sur rien
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit donc c'est pas
la peine de de s'engager dans une fausse
amitié je vois bien l'intérêt que vous
avez à dire que vous êtes venu me voir
c'est pas parce que ça me permet de
toucher une droite souverainiste
conservatrice et 1
mais moi je veux pas de délit d'initié
dix n'ont pas de problème c'est très net
et puis le temps passe
alors au cours de cette conversation je
lui dis
le prochain président ne sera pas jugé
sur ce qu'il aura
changé sur ce qui leur a souvent sur ce
qu'il aura sauvé ce que je dis dans mon
livre
lieu est tout à fait et c'est
bon et puis le temps passe et puis je
m'aperçois
que en fait je suis une caution
et je me le dis à ce moment là attention
et ce qu'ils cherchent un baiser oui je
cherche à me baiser
en tout cas à m'utiliser comme il a
utilisé d'autres oui
il eut alors c'est vieux c'est vieux
comme la politique mais simplement il ya
un moment donné il faut avoir un souci
d'honnêteté c'est à dire que moi à ce
moment il ya des gens qui me disent ah
mais c'est curieux vous êtes
souverainisme et macro et européiste
heure du coup ben nous on est on est les
deux heures et là je me dis mais faut
pas que j'entraîne par une attitude
ambiguë
au nom de l'amitié avec macron
des gens que je trompe ainsi
donc je dis stop
et en fait je vais aller comment il a
pris comme on l'attendait mais je vais
vous dire comment parce que il ya eu un
dîner
que je raconte le 4 mars donc 2019
et en fait il m'avait invité à dîner on
était tous les 3es était chez lui ou
dans la maison tous les français dans la
maison de tous les français si ça avait
été chez lui je l'aurais pas raconter
je considère que lundi neige chez lui
c'est un dîner privé si c'est la maison
de tous les français
il n'y a pas de paroles secrète en tout
cas pas avec moi
et là en fait ça a dérapé
il s'est énervé s'est mis en colère ça
donne quoi macron qui se met en colère à
bas israël il pose sa serviette et
tourne les talons et la politique de la
chaise vide oui c'est ça et à brigitte
parce que brigitte l'a fait une remarque
en dix ans adorent y écouter philippe
parce que ce que vient de dire c'est
vrai bon après ou avant fini ton
assiette
avant quoi fini ton assiette
c'est une boue zii continuer et
sa danse
vous en rajoutez la
baie est pas besoin de ça parce que les
assiettes étaient prêtes à voler à ce
point là non mais il était en fait
s'élever pourquoi pas contre moi contre
elle
parce que venait de lui dire qu'elle
était plutôt d'accord avec moi sur
toutes les questions
régalien qu'elle était plus trop
d'accord avec lui c'est plus trop
d'accord avec lui et voilà bref mais
finalement comme il est malin il sait
dire où le jeu je vois le talon qui
tourne il revient et c'est un bon mais
en fait ça s'est mal passé bombe et
après
après vous j'ai jugé que
je pouvais plus conçu au nez des choses
c'est ce fameux en même temps c'est en
fait je vais vous prendre une image le
mec qui m'a dit
comme ça a commis c'est en descendant
l'escalier de la cinéscénie je suis venu
chercher ici l'écho profonde et
tendresse française
et qui ensuite dit à une télévision
américaine il faut déconstruire
l'histoire de france
je me dis il ya un baiser c'est la
chercher le baiser dans la salle
et je veux dit le baiser c'est moi
mais si je n'ai pas le courage de rompre
les liens
parce que c'est toujours agréable d'être
l'ami du roi
si j'ai pas le courage de mes liens gens
traînent derrière moi des gens qui
équipent arcandor
aujourd'hui rebat nous
on aime philippe de villiers on aime
macro donc on votre mac row
et en fait le moment où tout a basculé
c'est le moment où en âme et conscience
je me suis dit
il est nocif pour la france
parce qu'en fait et n'a pas le goût de
la france
est en fait parce que j'ai découvert au
fil du temps parce qu'il a été fait à
davos
grande cérémonie young global leaders
donc c'est un enfant de davos
j'ai découvert aussi
as une conversation avec jacques attali
au cirque d'hiver global leader c'est un
lyon leader s'il ya un nicolas dupont
aignan qui a été oublié dans son sinon
la peking leader a détrôné nom et il ya
eu c'est marrant d'ailleurs schiappa et
à thala l'aurions global leader soues
laisser ses de toute l'ambiance des
cabinet mckinsey
c'est le happy management
c'est
la fameuse phrase de sociologues onglets
qui dit à ceux qui s'occupent qui sont
proches des people from somewhere des
people from any where lui c'est any
where ceci donc pas fera la chanson de
jacques brel
t'as voulu voir vesoul et on l'a vu ta
mère tu as voulu voir ta soeur et on a
vu en fleurs
à la lui c'est t'as voulu voir vesoul et
on a vu davos
est en fait ces deux pères spirituels
c'est jacques attali
qui a dit j'ai inventé macron
l'expression est de lui et dans le livre
date gildas
et klaus schwab le président du forum de
davos
il ya pas henry hermand autres les doux
tout le monde bien sûr c'est pas des
choses influence mais quand même c'est
intéressant attali qui veut une
gouvernance mondiale
et klose fab
qui
veut installer la suzeraineté et le
messianisme de la théophanie numérique
donc en fait macron
il accomplit en quelque sorte un
programme il suit une feuille de route
qui le rend
absolument imperméable au gilet jaune
il ya des gens comme moi
c'est à dire qu'en fait une
il s'intéresse pas aux temps longs
il a jamais vécu dans une entreprise
si vous me permettez à
un petit portrait
dont j'ai parlé avec brigitte
d'abord c'est l'enfant du touquet il va
au casino tout jeune
vous avez jamais tout casino non mais
c'est pas la question vous avez déjà été
aux courses
je suis allée oui en spectateurs oui
mais jamais paris non mais c'est gagnant
will 1 mais je comprends très bien oui
si vous n'aimez pas ce que je comprends
très bien les parieurs etc et d'ailleurs
comment je suis passé sur les 116 ans
mais moi je crois qu'au paris donc
quand ils sont parce que c'est la gueule
ayew paris ou aux probabilités
je crois aux deux géants paris
probabilité je crois au jeu mais
simplement
attention à ce que ça ne devienne pas le
fond du caractère et lui en fait ils
jouaient joyent perdait souvent
m'a-t-on dit et qui vous et 10,1 à metz
alors je vais vous dire c'est très
simple c'est son
un de ses meilleurs amis de l'époque qui
jouait avec lui au touquet tous les
soirs
il a perdu combien et je n'en sais rien
mais sous les je me suis dit hé regarde
la france que me et la société comme un
jeu de dominos et d'ailleurs il a eu une
expression quand je vais demander aux
plus floue vers vous allez être candidat
si jeune il a répondu
je prends mon risque
c'est une expression de jeu je prends
mon risque en ce wiki ou de banquiers
oui mais vous de banquiers ou les deux
ensuite il ya le jeune homme qui monte
sur les planches
amiens
et
qui est fasciné par la phrase de jouvet
le théâtre c'est le verbe
et croit que le verbe suffit vers
performatif chauny il croit que le verbe
c'est l'action vous remarquerez souvent
il intervient à la télévision ayant à
faire ce serait faire cela c'est fait
mais non le thé le tiers de ces le verbe
mais le terreau ne s'est pas la vie
justement le verbe c'est pas l'action et
troisième trait de caractère c'est le
yom le young global leaders qui
qui
est
dans
l'idée
du cabinet mckinsey d'ailleurs ma keynes
est omniprésent dans le quinquennat
au début pour l'épidémie gérer
l'épidémie c'est le cabinet mckinsey
mckinsey macron
une espèce de parenté
intime
de cet enfant du virtuel
qu'est qui n'augure 1
un homme a peut de nouveau un homme
politique un peu nouveau qui est l'homme
qui zappe l'homo sapiens
souverainisme c'était mieux ça non oui
nouveau sapient c'est vous qui l'avez
inventé ça nous appuient ans
l'homme qui zappe et vous remarquerez
zappé
voulait continuer sur votre avis macro
où on peut passer à autre chose ah ben
moi je suis là pour répondre à vos
questions donc vous m'emmener vous
voulez comme en balade le bruyant dans
les temps
pourquoi pourquoi est il allé à la manif
police avec zemmour beitia
quel message il a voulu soutenir
question interne est très simple j'ai
répondu à cette question d'une phrase
parce que la police et le dernier
rempart de la paix civile
question internet
le sur l'hydrologie si clean et ils
pastis pastis était une blague le pastis
vous avez hugo vide il ya combien de
temps déjà
3 mois 3 mois vous avez encore des
anticorps donc ouais et le pastis tu es
une blague mais c'est comme c'est comme
vous avez un gastro entérologue vous
avez balle aux ventes il dit pète un
coup oui c'était une blague le pasteur
je réponds à votre question
en fait quand j'ai eu le co lead j'ai
manifesté comment quel type de symptômes
pour coup au beau jeu
je sentais que j'avais de la fièvre
et une petite perte d'appétit
je suis faible
et j'ai fait un test
avec mon médecin et donc le test c'est
positif
et là j'ai appelé le professeur raoul
parce que je suis entré en contact il ya
longtemps un nom avec lui et on est
entre nous deux une sympathie réciproque
j'aime beaucoup le professeur out
et
je lui dis voilà j'ai le coït bon il me
dit voilà devrait prendre ceci cela et
settat et je lui dis
est ce que vous croyez toujours boire
mon astuce parce que je ne vois pas
beaucoup d'alcool
sauf avec les copains mais du 20 mai
j'aime bien j'aime bien le pastis
et me dit on c'est très bon hockey aucun
problème ça me fera ça ne peut faire que
du bien
le temps passe et je fais une émission
avec apolline de malherbe
il ya peu de temps et elle me dit on dit
que vous avez le collège le professeur
raoul raconté jeudi d'ailleurs j'ai pris
et me dit vous avez pris coche du beau
jeu plusieurs médicaments et puis mon
pastis
edit ah bon bon
il se passe rien
et là j'entends une sorte de deuxième
degré
donc je suis là et là chez pro jeudi
voilà le pastis état et et j'ai
correspondu ce matin avec eux françois
août et je lui ai dit
les gens n'ont pas compris le deuxième
degré
et là des deux a répliqué le
51e degrés
pas mal pas mal avec ou sans glaçons
avec
vous avez gardé des séquelles de votre
qu'ovide ce que vous avez ce qu'on
appelle un coup vide locaux vides à
séquelles
pas de perte de mémoire pas de perte de
diction
et bientôt rien du tout est ce que vous
êtes au courant des séquelles du coc
vide oui quel type de séquelles locaux
vides peut laisser bah écoute et j'en ai
entendu parler mais
ça reste des cas assez rare
que sous vos sources bah écoutez ma
connaissance
c'est pas si rare que ça les séquelles
du coc vide ces mêmes les patients qui
ont trouvé le terme coville ou non alors
n'enrichit vous dit ça pourquoi ce que
moi j'ai dans mon environnement j'ai eu
j'ai connu beaucoup de gens courent il
qu il vous avertit le quotidien as qui
autour de vous
votre femme vous personne en personne
non quand vous avez été diagnostiqué
positif ouais vous avez fait tester tout
le monde chez vous absolument
et mais je me suis mis à l'écart
et
les gens que j'ai vu c'est pour ça je
fais cette réponse qui sont notre fausse
puisque vous êtes plus scientifique que
moi ou jelloun tradition médecin oui non
mais je ne sais pas en tout cas moi j'ai
parmi mes amis j'ai pas vu de pertes de
mémoire j'ai pas vu de ma famille c'est
un
oui mais voilà
ces possibles pertes de mémoire perte
d'odorat attaque sur l'autre alors moi
je sais pas j'ai pas eu ça j'ai pas eu
la perte d'odorat sinon j'aurais pas je
vais attaquer patick oui
mais là je veux rassurer des gens mais
c'est pas parce que yancovici pas parce
que il ya les masques c'est pas parce
que on est tous dans la détresse parce
qu'on est dans le désarroi c'est pas
parce qu'on a peur il faut perdre
l'humour au contraire je pense mais bon
alors s'il ya des gens que ça a choqué
je me suis au près de qom et
quelque chose me dit que
le fait de boire un peu d'alcool
c'est pas mauvais pour la santé
avec modération j'ai
connu une grand tante qui est qui à
l'âge de 95 ans burress en verre de
bordeaux
ok
il cannabis dans tout ça le cannabis
récréatif et le cannabis thérapeutique
alors
sur le cannabis thérapeutique je me
prononcerai pas parce que je suis pas
médecin
sur le cannabis récréatif comme vous
dites un créatif un petit coup de 51
alors là je vous ramener à oka précédent
sur locaux vides à mon avis le commis de
laisse des traces des zhu c'est possible
c'est probable le cannabis
beaucoup plus l'alcool
à l'alcool lorsqu'il est consommé de
manière modérée comme le tabac
d'ailleurs
dans le tabac c'est vraiment nocifs
l'alcool quand il est con crs quand il
est consommé sans modération
produit un désastre le cannabis
avec modération sont excellents
justement
le cannabis
vous empoisonne lentement mais vous
empoisonne
et
c'est un problème que je connais bien
parce que j'ai eu à le traiter dans
votre famille non quand j'étais
président du conseil général de la
vendée
puisque j'étais président mais pendant
20 ans du centre hospitalier
départemental d'orient
donc souhait c'est quelque chose qui me
fait mal même d'en parler
parce que j'ai vu
et donc les gens qui disent
non ya pas de problème ça se passe bien
et ils connaissent pas ils n'ont pas vu
le problème le cannabis laisse des
traces indélébiles
sans parler de la surenchère mais laisse
des traces indélébiles et
alors je sais bien que cette position
est aujourd'hui impossible puisque tout
le monde dit là où le nom fouet
tolérance c'est une histoire de
tolérance de toulon en france on est le
premier concert on est le premier pays
consommateur de cannabis ray
ou financent le maroc grâce à ça on
finance les pays de type amsterdam grâce
à 100 finances des mafias on se retrouve
avec des substances qui sa voisine plus
proche des drogues dures que du cannabis
de mai 68 que vous n'avez jamais connu
et que la guerre contre la drogue ne
fonctionne pas alors je peux vous
répondre là-dessus asie
le la guerre contre la drogue ne
fonctionne pas parce qu'on veut pas
l'amener par un psy ont dû au maroc
terminé
9es
on arrête non mais c'est si si si on
considère que faut pas utiliser la force
parce que face à la force hier à la
violence bombe en fait plus rien
donc si on voulait vraiment éradiquer le
problème de la drogue
en prêt comment alors mais d'abord il
faut agir sur l'approvisionnement
donc on sait très bien la filière
marocaine on connaît pas qui on sera
donc
d'abord l'approvisionnement donc en fait
on apercevra genou on arrête il n'y a
plus d'approvisionnement lourdes igloo
et un banc du mans ensuite
on fait sauter tous les petits points de
vente
et on est impitoyable en termes de
sanctions pénales
pour les trafiquants je parle pas des
victimes je parle des trafiquants
et ce qu'ils disent il faut dépasser le
cannabis comme au portugal ouais ben
justement
qu'est ce qu'on constate
non pour tullia c'est spécial c'est un
système de grades duel assez intelligent
d'ailleurs et vous il est assez
compliqué on dit nous ils ont dépénalisé
toutes les denrées à ben je sais pas
alors je me trompe
mais en fait ce qui se passera
c'est que il y aura un marché légal
avec un cas d'avis
qu'on appellera le cannabis propre et il
y aura toujours un marché légal parce
que ce sera beaucoup plus facile d'aller
acheter moins cher son cannabis
illégal donc arrêté en ne fera
qu'amplifier le problème quand vous
étiez président du conseil général le g
du cannabis était un combien le gramme
d'herbe et à combien chez vous je ne me
souviens pas
je suis pas assez au fait de la question
du cannabis j'ai jamais été
comment un voisin du cannabis donc je
peux pas vous le dire
est-ce que vous avez trois livres a
conseillé notre communauté est-ce que
vous avez trois livres a conseillé à
notre communauté
3 lire
vous avez pas droit de cité les vôtres
c'est un tricheur oui
alors céder tout dépend si vous voulez
des livres qu'elle trois livres
importants à lire pour les jeunes à
papus alors jeu dans ce cas là je vous
le dis
dans l'ordre
pour avoir le goût du ciel bleu
et et en même temps des contradictions
de la vie et de ce qui fait le bonheur
malgré tout par les harmonies intime
verlaine n'importe quoi de verlaine
verlaine si le reniement de saint pire
c'est à dire donc je continue je vous
écoute
ensuite
chateaubriand parce que c'est la
littérature la grande littérature
et que si on veut aimer la langue
française voilà
c'est le grand cru par excellence
et ses traits à yves pour aujourd'hui
dont j'oublie le titre soumis
l'insoumission de sonia mabrouk parce
qu'elle dit comment
d'origine tunisienne s'est mise à aimer
la france et celui je me fait pleurer
beaucoup de tendresse
et de rêve parce que je me dis mais donc
c'est possible
il faut savoir que je vais vous dire une
chose que je vous ai pas encore dit
c'est que moi ayant créé ce que j'ai
créé moi j'ai créé le vendée globe je
crée le puits le fou ça marche puisque
quand manuel valls me dis je vais au puy
du fou je suis dit lequel quand même le
grand luz l'agresseur est ce que c'est
la france où tolède sita est bien ce que
je veux dire c'est pas je suis pas en
train de faire un exercice d'auto
éblouissement non ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que quand on crée on est
optimiste on est on est en permanence
dans l'optimisme est ma devise à moi je
me souviens quand j'avais 18 ans et est
une société se sauvent non pas par des
mises en garde les par des réalisations
qu'on accroche à contre pente
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations une bouteille à la
mer quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur les réseaux
je leur conseille
d'entreprendre il mène à bien double
voyage
un premier
un voyage dans les beautés française
rien de tel que le lieu la puissance du
lieu
quand vous allez
enfin
plus voyage dans le monde plus je me
disais ça qu'avec mon fils récemment
c'est le plus beau pays du monde quoi et
donc en fait
le voyage vous donne
excite vos sens pendant qu
on écoute la cigale en
toutes les fleurs de franska et puis il
ya tous ces témoignages de pierre qui
vous rendent à votre humanité parce
qu'on se dit cela il ya des gens
cohabiter il y a eu
il ya la trace la cicatrice de la grande
histoire du talent pour me venger le
deuxième voyage c'est
le voyage dans l'histoire pourquoi parce
que l'histoire est une deuxième mémoire
vous avez votre vie et avec l'histoire
la vie des autres et en fait vous vous
comparez vous comparez ce qui leur est
arrivé ce qui vous arrive
enfin et si vous regardez l'amour
courtois au moyen-âge
découvrez
une forme d'amour et d'élégance que vous
aider dans vos sentiments à vous et en
fait c'est le double voyage fort intime
c'est comme ça croit elle
moi quand j'étais petit je voyais que
des adultes qui me disait
c'est mon dernier message pour les
jeunes mais le plus important je voyais
que les adultes qui me disait
prêt soit dans les petits parce que
quand tu seras adultes l'oréal temps
attrapera
et en fait j'ai fui le réel j'ai suivi
mon rêve et je vais réaliser
philippe de villiers merci merci à vous
[Musique]
e
com
[Musique]